So Leute, ich bin am Start, ich hab das voll verlernt, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie man strebt, wie strebt man eigentlich richtig?
Wie geht das, wie macht man das richtig?
Ich muss glaube ich erstmal sagen, dass ich alle meine Follower liebe und ich euch unglaublich dankbar bin, dass ihr mir followt und ihr meine T-Shirts kaufen soll.
Ich glaube das ist das Beste, das muss man machen als richtiger Streber.
Also Leute, an mir geht ja in letzter Zeit dieses ganze YouTube Streaming Zeug, ich krieg ja nix mal richtig mit.
Und letztens bin ich auf Twitch gegangen, hab mal so geguckt, welche Games sind da angesagt auf Twitch?
Moment, ich werde angeschrieben.
Skype in 2k80, alter ich muss das jetzt ausmachen.
Skype, ich glaub's net.
Ich glaub's net, Skype.
Stellt euch das mal vor, könnt ihr euch das vorstellen? Skype, ernsthaft, ja?
Leute, habt ihr Qualitätsoptionen im Video?
Ich hab jetzt Twitch aus Tricksettings gemacht.
Ich hab jetzt eingestellt 900p 5995 Bits pro Sekunde.
Bäm.
Das ist fast so viel wie FPS das Auge sehen kann.
Ja, was wollte ich dann grad erzählen?
Ähm, ja genau, ich war letztens auf Twitch.
Und es geht ja alles um mal, was will ich jetzt eigentlich machen?
Also der Grund warum ich Stream angemacht hab ist, weil BDO-Quests so unglaublich langweilig sind.
Und ich mir gedacht hab, da kann ich ein bisschen schwätzen, während wir BDO-Quests machen.
Was muss ich denn machen? Ich muss Quests machen.
Genau, ich muss 4 Marni-Stones Baschims voll machen, 4 Marni-Stones Katris voll machen,
4 Marni-Stones Desert Naga voll machen.
Irgendwo hier war das, ne?
Und ich muss 4 Marni-Stones Fogens Alter voll machen.
Das heißt wir machen jetzt erstmal Baschims voll.
Ich hab hier noch Platz drin.
So.
Übrigens, ich hab nichts aktualisiert, also das Gear stimmt nicht, was der Nightbot raushaut und so.
Das ist alles outdated, overrated, debated.
So.
Ja, dann hab ich Stones dabei.
Da hab ich 1 Stone, da bringt es jetzt nicht.
Wir brauchen ja...
Ich hab da noch mehr Stones, ich muss da noch mehr haben, oder?
Baschims Stone, 1 Baschims...
Ah doch, ich hab 3, hier sind 3.
Okay, dann planten wir den mal ein und rennen.
Weil ich hab meinen Gaul sonst wo stehen, wir rennen jetzt einfach zu Baschims runter.
Aber mit dem neuen Speed-Buff, ich gemerkt, geht es voll ab.
Guck dich mal an, wie der Wizard flitzt.
Seht ihr das hier?
Wie er abgeht, der Wizard.
Der flitzt schneller als mein komisches Level-3-Horse.
Der flitzt richtig ab.
Wir müssen eine Sache nochmal testen.
Ist die In-Game-Lautstärke okay?
Hat man das, ja?
Dann hört man die Musik im Hintergrund.
Ich hab voll verlernt, wie man strebt.
Kann das nicht mehr.
Genau, Sebaro.
Wie gesagt, Sebaro, ich hab das voll verlernt.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob meine Settings richtig sind.
Ich hab festgestellt, dass OBS beim Upgrad meine Settings gelöscht hat.
Aber glücklicherweise hatte ich auf dem anderen Rechner noch mein Setup drauf und konnte es dann rüber kopieren.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum OBS so Zeug macht.
So, ich wollte doch irgendwas erzählen gerade.
Ha, ich weiß. Ach ja, der Gear stimmt nicht.
Ach, wir können das gerade, was wir machen können.
Das wäre super, wenn das einer der Mods machen könnte.
Ich plant mal mein neues Gear ein und könnte mal screenshotten und das updaten.
Ich plante mal mein neues Gear ein und könnte mal screenshotten und das updaten.
Ah, neues Gear. Easy Ted Dande seit gestern.
Einfach so, paar Mal geklickt, da Frasier, bam Ted Dande, easy.
Es wäre schön, wenn das einer der Mods updaten konnte.
Ich meine, ich habe ja schon gesagt immer, ich bin der best ausgerüstete Noob in diesem Game aller Zeiten.
Aber jetzt stimmt das wirklich.
Ach doch, Sebaro, klar, du kannst das auch von Twitter nehmen.
Stimmt, da habe ich da gepostet.
Da habe ich gar nicht mehr dran gedacht, siehst du.
Voll planlos.
So, was wollte ich denn jetzt erzählen?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich kriege das ja alles nicht so mit, was da auf Twitch passiert.
Und mir war schon klar irgendwie, dass Fortnite voll angesagt ist.
Aber ich habe das überhaupt nicht gecheckt, dass Fortnite so angesagt ist.
Ich habe letztens geguckt, welche Games werden dann viel gestreamt auf Twitch.
Gucken wir mal.
Und das sehe ich da irgendwie so, Fortnite irgendwie 175.000 Zuschauer oder so.
Ich denke, boah, krasser Scheiß.
Und gucke ich rein.
Und da ist da ein Typ drinne mit 150.000 Zuschauer.
So, und das habe ich ja dann auf Twitter geschrieben und irgendwie hat da keiner verstanden, dass es voll an mir vorbei gegangen ist.
Anscheinend wusste das jeder, nur ich nicht.
Ich habe das überhaupt noch mitgekriegt.
Ja, so ist das.
Ich habe das überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe das null mitgekriegt, dass es einen Typ gibt mit 150.000 Zuschauern.
Ich meine, 150.000, das ist übertrieben krass, wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Also normalerweise war ja, sag mal so, wenn du über 10.000 Zuschauer auf Twitch hast, das war so massive, weißt du?
Über 10.000 hast du zu den 10 größten oder so gehört, so nach dem Motto.
Und jetzt 150 WTF.
150.000.
Das ist, da fällt mir gar kein Vergleich dazu ein.
Das ist übertrieben viel.
Und den Kerl gibt es ja anscheinend noch nicht so lang.
Ich habe von dem vorher niemals gehört.
Und ich habe das überhaupt nicht, ich habe den Stream, der Stream war auf der, genau, der Stream, der kam dann irgendwann mal zwischendurch, zwischendurch auf der Startzeit oder so.
Ich habe das überhaupt nicht gecheckt.
Ich habe irgendwie so gedacht, das wäre irgendwie Soda Poppin jetzt mit blauen Haaren oder so was.
Also ich guck ja beides nicht großartig, bis ich dann irgendwann gecheckt habe, ne, das ist ja ein ganz anderer.
Und das ist einer, der noch viel, das ist ja ein ganz anderer.
Und das ist ein ganz anderer, der noch viel, das ist ja ein ganz anderer.
Und das ist einer, der noch viel, viel hunderttausendfach mehr Views hat.
Was geht denn auf Twitch zur Zeit ab?
Moment, Moment, wo, wo gehe ich hier überhaupt hin?
Hier will ich gar nicht hin.
Ich will, ich will hier rüber.
Lol.
Das, das überfordert mein Gehirn einfach immer.
Bis der Stream und was in Game machen.
Das ist zu viel.
Was, Ninja hat mal einen Stream mit Drake gemacht und hat 600.000 Zuschauer gehasst.
Scheiße.
Muss ich mal überlegen, 600.000, ja.
Das haben Leute auf YouTube teilweise, die das seit 8 Jahren oder so.
Ich mein, klar gibt es natürlich auch welche, die haben das viel schneller und viel mehr und so.
Aber 600.000, das ist ja, das ist quasi, quasi fast schon Mainstream Fernsehsender so.
Das ist, das ist echt heftig.
Ich, ich will nicht wissen, ich mein Fortnite, also hier Epic Games, die müssten den ja komplett auf Händen tragen, ne.
Oder Twitch auch im Endeffekt.
Der hat wahrscheinlich schon die, die, die persönlichen Twitch Assistenten am Start.
Die Tag und Nacht da irgendwie am Start sind und sich darum kümmern, dass er irgendwie jeden Wunsch von den Augen, äh, von den Lippen abgelesen bekommt.
Die müssen den echt, das ist, keine Ahnung.
Das ist ultra viel.
Kommt mal da rein, einer rum.
Ups.
Ja.
Man kriegt jetzt auch irgendwie Knowledge von Mops, obwohl man die schon mal hatte.
Das ist jetzt auch neu.
Also neu, ja wisst ihr, wisst ihr neu.
Also für mich ist das neu.
Das ist vor irgendwie seit 5 Patches oder so.
Ich lese gleich Chat, ich blick gerade natürlich, das ist zu viel.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal auf den Berg rauf.
Komische DK oder was ist das, kann, kann zwar pissen, alter.
Ne, ist das Schreiger?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Was ist denn das?
Ne, ist es The Witch?
Ich kenne auch nicht mal die Klassen von dem Spiel.
Schaust du Overwatch League?
Ja.
Aber die letzten Matches habe ich nicht mehr so ausführlich geguckt.
Wann kommt ein neues Videothema? Keine Ahnung.
Weil ich bin zurzeit so damit beschäftigt, mein Haus intelligent zu machen.
Mit Heimautomatisierungszeug.
Ich habe gerade überhaupt nicht mehr an Videos gedacht in letzter Zeit.
Du trittst so viel Zeit, das ist einfach...
Ich sage euch Leute, Heimautomatisierung, das ist ein fast ohne Boden.
Oh, BTF.
Ich krieg, ich krieg Donations.
Krieg Donations.
Dass ich mir neuen Heimautomatisierungs Spielkram kaufen kann.
10 Euro, danke. 10 Euro. Endlich mal wieder Donations raushauen.
Lul.
Hattest du dir schon den Screenshot von der Stream-Archive-Seite...
Fuck, jetzt ist die Donation weggegangen.
Jetzt muss ich gleich noch mal gucken.
Warte mal.
Was war das?
Tippy Stream?
Was war Tippy Stream?
Ich glaube schon.
Ja, Donations.
Was hat er geschrieben?
Endlich mal wieder Donations raushauen.
Hattest du dir schon den Screenshot von der Stream-Archive-Seite angeschaut?
Ich bin jetzt schon ein Stück weiter, aber Web-Entwicklung ist wirklich...
Was?
Äh...
Nee, ich habe mir den Screenshot nicht... Welcher Screenshot?
Ach doch, du hast...
Doch!
Ah nee, das habe ich mir nicht angeschaut.
Das habe ich nur so aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen und es voll vergessen.
Du hast irgendwas auf Twitter geschickt, ne?
Das musst du mir nochmal schicken.
Ich habe das voll vergessen.
Voll verpeilt.
Ja, nee, das habe ich...
Jetzt wo du es sagst, fällt es mir wieder ein.
Das habe ich voll vergessen.
Es ruckelt.
BDO.
Weißt du, BDO ist auch so ein geiles Game.
Konstant 144 FPS.
Ich weiß, das Auge sieht nur 12, aber ansonsten ist das kein Problem.
Ähm...
Aber trotzdem immer wieder mal eine Sekunde Ruckler zwischendurch.
Übrigens, ne, mit diesen, das Auge sieht 12, kannst du permanent Leute in Twitch-Chats triggern.
Heute Morgen habe ich Dings...
Äh...
Speedrun in Dings...
Deutschland...
Germany Speedrun Marathon.
Oder sowas geguckt.
Und einfach auch immer wieder so aus Spaß an der Freude in Chat reingespampt.
Irgendwie Human Eye Auge sieht 12 FPS.
Und da kam schon gleich wie die ersten...
Nein, nein, das ist überhaupt nicht so.
Das Auge sieht nicht in FPS.
Und auch bist du dumm, dass du sowas schreibst.
Also wenn man die Leute irgendwie triggern will, dass sie darauf reagieren, schreibt das Auge sieht nur 12 FPS.
Das ist das sicherste.
Hast du Shadowplay im Hintergrund laufen?
Ich habe immer Shadowplay laufen, ja.
Aber das habe ich auch mit Shadowplay oder ohne OBS vollkommen egal.
Das ist BDO.
BDO ruckelt immer alle paar Sekunden, wann du es...
Also...
Natürlich war alle paar Sekunden...
BDO ruckelt immer an speziellen Stellen ruckelt.
Guck hier, das hier zum Beispiel.
Wenn du hier vorgehst...
Wenn du vordashst an der Stelle...
Wenn ich jetzt eine Runde gelaufen bin und dash wieder an der Stelle, ruckelt es wieder.
Das ist halt BDO.
Das ist halt High Quality Programming am Start.
Bipolar Abyss.
Also die anderen wahrscheinlich...
Was waren das?
Waren das Koreaner?
Süd-Süd-Korea kamen die, oder?
Bipolar Abyss, waren das...
Haben sie halt die Koreaner irgendwie eben programmiert?
Tank sitzen, die dürfen da erst raus nach 15 Stunden.
Wenn sie irgendwas fertig programmiert haben.
Dementsprechend, das sieht es wahrscheinlich doch aus.
Warum ist es denn schon wieder so voll?
Ich war heute Morgen schon mal da, keine Sauer am Start.
So Leute, ich lese gleich Chat.
Es ist zu viel rot.
Ja, irgendjemand hat gefragt, ob ich Overwatch spiele.
Guck, guck, ich...
Wobei ich sagen muss, dass ich das Interesse hatte,
haben wir in letzter Zeit ein bisschen nachgelassen.
Aber ich habe ja am Anfang viel geguckt.
Aber nachdem ich selbst nicht spiele gerade...
Und in nächster Zeit habe ich auch ein bisschen nachgelassen.
Und ich habe auch ein bisschen nachgelassen.
Aber ich habe am Anfang viel geguckt.
Aber nachdem ich selbst nicht spiele gerade...
Und in nächster Zeit auch nicht vorhabe.
Weil mich Overwatch einfach so krass abfuckt wie kein anderes Game.
Und ich habe ja viel geguckt.
Ich würde mal sagen, ich habe fast jedes Match zumindest Watt-mäßig geguckt.
Was natürlich auch geil ist.
Du kriegst ja...
Es gibt ja irgendwelche Watch-Achievements.
Aber natürlich nicht, wenn du Watt guckst.
Und die EU-Zeiten sind halt komplett für den Arsch.
So, nachdem Dallas so auf den Sack kriegt,
habe ich eigentlich gar keinen Bock mehr zu gucken.
Außerdem finde ich das Observing auch teilweise sehr fragwürdig.
Und nachdem diese...
Wisst ihr, wo ich aufgehört habe, im Overwatch League zu gucken?
Weil ich es so bescheuert fand,
dass war diese TriHard 7 Kontroverse,
falls ihr es hier mal mitgekriegt habt.
TriHard 7.
Also wenn jetzt jemand TriHard 7 schreibt,
ist das Ultra-Racism.
Man weiß zwar nicht so genau warum,
aber es ist ganz, ganz schlimm.
TriHard 7.
Darf man nicht.
Hallo Dominik Meyers.
Gibt es sonst irgendwelchen E-Sport,
den du regelmäßig guckst?
Also wie gesagt,
ich habe relativ viel Overwatch geguckt.
Aber in letzter Zeit gucke ich...
Was ich immer gerne gucke,
obwohl ich überhaupt keine Ahnung von dem Game habe,
also null Plan,
selbst noch nie gespielt habe, ist StarCraft.
StarCraft gucke ich extrem gerne.
Ich habe das Gefühl von allen E-Sports,
ist so...
StarCraft lebt so auch richtig davon,
dass du Caster hast,
die Ahnung haben von dem, was sie erzählen.
Weil du musst da so genau wissen,
an welcher Stelle du gucken musst,
an welcher Stelle du was zeigen musst,
und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber wenn du da ein gutes Turnier hast
mit guten Castern,
ich meine StarCraft ist nicht mehr so gross,
wie das Blizzard, was ich gerne hätte.
Und ich war mehr in Korea.
Aber StarCraft gucke ich immer gerne,
wenn was ist.
Gucke wie es ruckelt.
Pass mal auf,
da vorne ruckelt es wieder an der gleichen Stelle.
Das ist halt WDO.
Übrigens, wer denkt,
wir sind hier oben fertig mit 300 von 500,
weit gefehlt.
Wir müssen das Ganze danach noch zweimal machen.
Und danach müssen wir an den nächsten Spot.
Und das viermal machen.
Und danach müssen wir
an den nächsten Spot das viermal machen.
Und dann sind wir fertig.
Und dann kommt wahrscheinlich die nächste Quest,
dass man das achtmal machen muss.
MonkaS.
Kennst du das Spiel Ozo? Klar.
Kennen tut das wahrscheinlich jeder.
Es waren alle.
Ach ja, ich hatte es vorhin schon mal gefragt,
aber irgendwie die Antwort nicht realisiert.
Ist GameSound und Musik und sowas?
Passt das?
Was, Ehex, du meinst ernsthaft,
das liegt am Shadowplay?
Ich kann das mal probieren,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass es am Shadowplay liegt.
Ich kann das mal probieren.
GameSound Minimalizer.
Okay.
Ich mache es ein Prozentpunkt im Windows Mixer mal runter.
So.
So, jetzt besser.
Ui.
Guck hier, wieder die gleiche Stelle.
Immer an der Stelle Rockets, immer.
Weil die Map irgendwie so komisch nachlädt.
Wieder die gleiche Stelle.
Programmieren wir heute C-Sharp?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich muss erstmal diese komische Quest machen,
weil der FnZer hat gesagt,
wenn man diese Quest hier erledigt,
gibt es einen Gürtel,
der plus 15 AP gibt auf alle Mobs.
Das ist natürlich geil für Dual-Grind
an irgendwelchen höherleveligen Spots.
Wo sind die Mobs?
Wo?
Ist zu voll.
Ich glaube, ich muss mal runter.
An der anderen Seite können wir auch hier noch schnell voll machen,
die 500.
Guck mal, das geht doch schnell.
Flutscht.
Hast du mitbekommen...
Watt?
Ach komm mal, der Tio.
Hi, der Tio.
Äh, was?
Hast du mitbekommen, dass Another Serial was von Wiedervereinigung...
Hä?
Nö.
Hab ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Von was denn?
Hä?
Was gibt es denn da wieder zu vereinigen?
Ach so.
Nee, hab ich nix von mitgekriegt.
Ich glaub auch, dass der Zug irgendwie durch ist.
Ich glaub, der Zug ist durch.
Sagt man aber, oder?
Der Zug, nee, der ist abgefahren.
Der Zug ist abgefahren.
So, komm.
Ich glaub, der Zug ist abgefahren.
Ich mein, klar,
COD wird immer noch viel geguckt,
aber das ist nicht mehr das Game,
wo du jetzt quasi dir die ultrariesige Zuschauer-Sachen
aufbaust, instant so, oder?
Ach, 1. April.
Stimmt.
Ich hab's ja schon wieder vergessen,
dass heute alle lustig sind.
Lull.
Nein, das hab ich nämlich gekriegt.
1. April.
Ich hab's vorhin extra noch getwittert, 1. April.
Da sind sie alle besonders witzig wieder.
Ich bash den Typ jetzt.
Bam.
Watt, der lebt noch?
Warum lebt denn der Typ noch?
Oh nee, oh nee, jetzt will der mich bashen.
Da ist der Streiger.
Der Streiger.
Was macht er denn da?
Bashed.
Das war gar kein Streiger.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab mittlerweile so OP-Gears für alles bekommen.
Ich muss einfach...
Ich mein, wenn jemand gut spielt,
ich hab ja überhaupt keine Chance,
ich krieg einfach mega auf den Sack.
Aber dann ist das,
dass ich mittlerweile so gute Gear hab,
kann ich einfach mal 3 Spells drücken
bei Spielern wie bei den Monstern.
Wir sind einfach down.
Jetzt muss ich nur noch mal gucken,
wie viel Karma ich hab.
Seht man das?
Ach, da, ich hab noch genug.
Ich hab noch genug.
Yo, Shazy.
Shazier.
Das hast du richtig erkannt.
Woa.
Da gab's jetzt, Theo,
da gab's ein neues Erdogan in Woa,
hab ich gesehen.
Hier hoch hab ich es gesehen,
wieder an der gleichen Stelle zu gucken.
Ich mach das jetzt mal,
was er gesagt hat.
Ich mach jetzt mal Shadowplay aus.
Was?
Oh.
Mob, hau ab.
Ihr seht das nicht,
ich hab so ein komisches Shadowplay-Interface drüber,
was ich jetzt nicht erkenne.
Turn off.
So, it's Shadowplay off.
Schon wieder?
Donation.
Alter, jetzt geht's aber ab heute.
Schlag auf Schlag.
Mal schon mal Donation gucken.
Der Sebaro schon wieder.
Hattest du dir schon mal überlegt,
WoaBlox.tv
Max FPS als Domain zu mieten,
sonst würde ich dich dreimal sehen.
Ähm.
Ne.
Hab ich noch nicht.
Mach das, also kannst du das ruhig registrieren.
Wenn man es aus irgendwelchen Gründen braucht,
kann man das ja dann, dann traden oder so.
Ansonsten,
ich hab noch genug.
Ich hab noch genug.
Ansonsten kann ich das nachher auch machen.
Ich hab bei Nitrado noch.
Domains offen.
Gut haben und Zeug.
Aber kannst du das auch ruhig machen.
So, ich muss jetzt mal,
wirklich mal Chat durchscrollen.
Ich hab da nämlich viel übersehen.
Das lief so gut mit vielen Videos.
Ich,
ich mach grad einfach,
wie man es jetzt sieht.
Ich hab jetzt,
ich hab jetzt,
Na
Der eiskreuter klar habe ich das mit dem exklusiv mitgekriegt
Also falls irgendwas im chat übersehen hat schreibt einfach nochmal dabei
Bei
Erzähl mal voll im haus ich kann euch das gleich auch mal zeigen
Und ich erzähle es euch erstmal also wie gesagt ich bin ja gerade dabei hier bisschen haus automatisierungs
Und es ist ich sag euch leute es ist nicht normal was das das weißte man denkt sich so einfach
Hey bauste man in fenster fenster sensor dran bauste mal irgendwie ein thermostat oder sowas oder so ein automatisches ding an die heizung
Grad zum kontrollieren das ist ein fass ohne boden dieses haus automatisierungs zeug und das schlimme ist es gibt wieder
Fünf also mindestens fünf verschiedene sachen wie man geräte miteinander verwendet
Und wenn man die unterschiedlichen nennen was man standards was sind ja keine standards voll den ganzen unterschiedlichen herstellern noch
Dabei nimmt gibt es da wieder gibt es da wieder 100 sachen 100 100 verschiedene geräte die im prinzip das gleiche machen die aber nicht
Mitnehmen kompatibel sind da macht wieder jeder hersteller sein eigenem ist
Grausam
Ganz schlimm deswegen muss man gucken dass das alles passt
Und ich mache das hauptsächlich mit home assistant das ist ein heißen heim automatisierungs tool framework
Programmierumgebung so zwischendurch aus allem und da kann man fast alles drin einbinden und irgendwie miteinander verzahnen zum beispiel
Was richtig geil ist ich habe eine wiesmann heizung im keller das ist ein hersteller da kommt hier ein bisschen was in die haus
Was richtig geil ist ich habe eine wiesmann heizung im keller das ist ein hersteller da kommt hier aus hessen also die sind auch relativ bekannt
Die machen die haben auch die machen auch die heizung für den schleich in dubai oder so
Also sie machen schon ganz gescheites zeug und das ist total durch die brust ins augen wie man da die daten abgreift
Ich wollte einfach mitkriegen wenn die heizung den fehler wirft das macht die manchmal
Die dann dann leuchtet die heizung rot und man muss im keller gehen und knopf drücken problem ist man weiß erst ob die heizung kaputt ist
oder ob die heizung den fehler hat
Wenn sie nicht geht weil ansonsten kriegt man das nicht mit
So das war eigentlich so der aufhänger das ganze warum ich damit angefangen habe und um die sachen jetzt halt euch mal fest um die sachen
auslesen zu können aus der heizung gibt es einmal eine
Eine software vom hersteller die ist der totale crap die ist einfach nur total schlecht da gibt es das kostet irgendwie 200 euro
so ein komisches
Interface was man da dran schlöpsel an die heizung vom hersteller und die kann man nur mit der eigenen hersteller smartphone app auslesen
Und mit der smartphone app sieht man auch nicht mal fehler
Geschweige denn kann man nicht war das nicht mal was richtig damit machen also die offizielle lösung ist einfach kacke
so
aber glücklicherweise
Gibt es ja gitarre und leute und und und findige programmierer was gebastelt haben wenn man sich ein wie es man
Debug kabel holt beziehungsweise sich selbst eins lötet
Das ist usb kabel das ist quasi usb kabel mit zwei leds auf der anderen seite dran
und das ganze dann an raspberry pi 0 steckt oder 0w mit wlan und
sich die nötige software von github drauf haut dann kann man seine heizung auslesen
das heißt ich habe jetzt den raspberry pi im keller an meiner heizung dran und lese von dort
aus und meine heizung fehler hatten die letzten fehler und die wassertemperaturen
Jetzt möchte ich meinen klo
und
Da macht man wieder wie ist die lage
quest
Technisch ist die lage ziemlich aussichtslos
Wir müssen nämlich hier vier vier mani stones voll machen dann bei katri vier mani stones dann bei desert naga vier mani stones
Und dann bei desert folgen vier mani stones das dauert ewig
Das ist auch der grund warum ich stream angemacht habe ist so langweilig ist alles
Hab ich eigentlich wieder ein bisschen karma gekriegt
Ja
Zu
Was der iphone back ist schon gefixt ist ja langweilig da kann man gar keinen leuten der indische zeichen schicken
Wollte es heute ein schmaus probieren
Ich verstehe ähnlich warum apple
Also apple scheint es ja anfällig dafür zu sein dass wenn man dem iphone irgendwelche
Zeichen schickt dass es dann abkackt oder oder ja wenn es sich abkackt irgendwelche apps kaputt gehen oder sowas es gab doch es gab doch
Letzten auch schon mal sowas
Also
Also ich meine jetzt von vor ein paar wochen gab es auch schon mal sowas jetzt war es jetzt war es in so spezielles indisches zeichen
Was man schicken musste dass ein message nicht mehr geht und davor ich weiß gar nicht was es davor war
Da musste man auch dem konnte man auch dem iphone irgendein unicode zeichen schicken und dann ist es kaputt gegangen
Ich weiß nicht was die machen
Aber das hast du zumindest bei android nicht dafür hast du bei android andere probieren
Ich habe es übrigens mal wieder hier bei meiner bei meiner haus automatisierung sache gemerkt eine große unterschied zwischen ios und android
Und warum beides seine daseinsberechtigung haben
Ios ist halt einfach umlängen reglementierter und du kannst viele sachen nicht machen die unter android gehen
Dadurch dass es aber viel reglementierter ist
Können auch die ganzen app hersteller nicht irgendwelche scheiße machen die du nicht machen die du nicht haben willst
Also zum beispiel zum beispiel du kannst unser ios keine app länger als zehn minuten im hintergrund laufen lassen
Das geht nicht das macht ios macht die app aus
Die wird einfach gekillt vor dem betriebssystem was natürlich den großen vorteil hat selbst wenn irgendein app hersteller komische dinger macht
nach spätestens zehn minuten schluss
Das funktioniert nicht du kannst dich zwar bei ios subscriben zu irgendwelchen notifications und sonst was
Aber du kannst nichts kontinuierlich im hintergrund laufen lassen länger als zehn minuten es wird abgebrochen oder 30 sekunden über irgendwelche
background notifications oder was auch immer
So das ist bei android komplett anders
dementsprechend kannst du allerdings
Auch bei android viel besser automatisieren als wenn du irgendwie tasker nimmst
Und im hintergrund was laufen lässt das reagiert halt instant im hintergrund wenn du dem irgendwas schickst was halt bei ios gar nicht geht
Also das hat es hat beides irgendwie seine daseinsberechtigung
Wenn man wenn man halt noch noch basteln will also für anläutig basteln wollen ist android natürlich ein deutliches besseres system
weil als schlicht und ergreifende ios viele sachen nicht gehen
Dafür ist es unter ios um längeren einheitlicher an vielen stellen
Und es kann halt auch keiner mit den apps so viel zeugs machen ich meine man muss mal in den app store reingucken bei google da sind da sind teilweise
Apps drinnen wo ich mich nicht traue die runterzuladen
Wobei man sich ja eigentlich denken müsste wenn die im wenn die im offiziellen app store sind da wurden die ja schon insofern
Untersucht dass da nix drinne steckt aber manche apps die sehen schon so so hochgradig dubios aus und die kommen aus dem offiziellen app store
Da fragt man sich auch was was da die qualitätskontrolle von google manchmal macht
Das ist mir beispielsweise beim ios app store so noch nicht passiert da hat es noch keine bedenken mir eine app runterzuladen
Aber ich denke es hat beides eine daseinsberechtigung ich habe ja auch beides ich meine ich habe ein iphone
Ich habe mittlerweile es ist voll übertrieben wenn man sich das mal überlegt wir haben hier mittlerweile also ich habe ein iphone dann haben wir
Eins was überlegen
Eins zwei drei
Überlegen
Vier vier tablets eigentlich fünf aber das eine ist aus immer aus
Was ich über die jahre für für geräte ansammeln und es hat alles irgendwie verwendungszweck
Verwendungszweck
Dementsprechend habe ich auch alles schon ausprobiert sei es ios oder oder android sonst war es auch vieler mit rum gebastelt
Und ich verstehe diese ganze diskussion gar nicht was im endeffekt besser ist es ist wie bei allem es hat es hat
Seine daseinsberechtigung
Und vor allem ist halt die frage was man machen will
Deswegen dieses ganze wir flamen uns des todes hier weil das eine besser ist als das andere ist wieder mal total bescheuert
So wie viel braucht man hier noch
Null der ist 500 voll
Der ist fast voll danach noch einmal easy easy mode
Danach sind wir fertig das ging viel schneller als ich gedacht habe danach waren wir katris danach waren wir nagas und dann waren wir
Zum Schluss waren wir fogens desert fogens alter alter lan
Demnächst gibt es lan als eigene klasse habe ich gesehen
Das wird mich dann immer verwirren
Was macht man mit den vier tablets
Alles die tablets sind alles android
Sagen wir so eins ist permanent aus das ist nämlich noch das alte nvidia schild tablet wo angeblich der akku abfackeln kann
Das nächste ist das neue nvidia schild tablet das wird halt ganz normales tablet verwendet da haben wir noch ein asus zentral
Das wird auch als ganz normales tablet verwendet
Ein tecra note 7 das ist eigentlich nur das hängt am kühlschrank weil es einen magnetischen magnetischen boden hat da kann man halt sachen drauf gucken morgens
Das übrigens auch praktisch ist ein tablet mit magnetischen boden
Und
Ist was vergessen
Ah ja unten lenovo lenovo
Irgendein lenovo pad das haben wir das war witzig das haben wir mal auf
Das habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt das haben wir auf der gamescom bei g2a gekriegt
Seitdem seitdem g2a denkt ich bin schwul das habe ich euch schon fünfmal erzählt glaube ich im stream da
Dementsprechend konnten sie auch gar nicht sagen dass ich dass ich mein freund in anführungsstrichen mitbringe
Oh man Weil hätten sie was gesagt hätten sie was gesagt dann hätte sie dich ja wieder aufregen können
Hätten sie was gesagt dann hätte sie dich ja wieder aufregen können
Das habe ich also wir waren auch das ist vor vor vor vorletzte gamescom oder so als noch g2a zeug gemacht habe
2000 gar 2015 oder so alter verpiss dich ich will nur ein paar bashings bashing dann ist gut
Wir brauchen gar nicht mal viel wir brauchen noch
Komm wir brauchen noch nichts wir brauchen noch 400 bashings das ist noch gar kein ding
Bashing bash
Noch noch 400 stück
Und ich kann nicht so viele leute waschen weil das camera geht langsam wieder hoch
Also wir waren wir waren bei g2a auf der gamescom eingeladen zu irgendeiner
Sie haben es Pressekonferenz genannt es war nicht wirklich es war so eine werbeveranstaltung im endeffekt
Da hatten sie auch die da waren auch die die zwei csgo casters da die
Die auch mal g2a werbung machen weiß ich weiß ich gar nicht
Weiß gar nicht wie die heißen zumindest haben wir uns angemeldet davor
Beziehungsweise g2a hat uns gefragt wer kommen will bei ihren partnern
Da habe ich gesagt ja
Kommt vorbei und weil sie haben auch geschrieben gibt es irgendwie gift back
Okay können wir mal hingehen und habe ich hier angemeldet und habe ich gesagt ja ich bin in Begleitung wir sind zu zweit
Und ob das geht ja ja ist überhaupt kein problem und da waren wir dann da ich war mit Felix da mit meinem arbeitskollege
Und also mit dem ich meine ausbildung auch gemacht habe wir kennen das auch schon ewig
Und da waren wir dann oben halt beim beim eingang wo halt die die
Empfangsdame da von g2a gestartet hat und sind angemeldet
Einladungs e-mail gezeigt danach weil sie erst gesagt hat findet sie nichts und sonst war es und hat es halt gemeint ich darf nur alleine
Weil weil der felix stand halt irgendwie nicht drauf obwohl ich es halt vorher gefragt habe
Und da habe ich ihr halt erzählt ja aber das ist halt mein partner
Und irgendwie hat sie partner falsch verstanden hat mich halt nur ein bisschen doof angeguckt
Und dann hat sie dann mal da ist es noch nicht
Problem und es ist absolut fein und alles gut und selbstverständlich dürfen partner mit
Ein freund
Weil überlegt euch mal ja überlegt euch mal was passiert was da was da abgegangen wäre
Ich wäre irgendwie so was es gibt ja leute die denken das ist ja nicht so
Und jetzt stellt euch mal aus g2a sicht vorne ich wäre wirklich schwul und hätte mein freund mitgebracht und er hätte nicht mitgedurft
Und ich hatte dann auch auf twitter auf twitter gepostet das ist in g2a
Übelst hier sexistisch racism und und unterdrückung und alles da werden wir alle darauf angesprungen
Das ist das schlimmste was dir heutzutage passieren kann
Dass du irgendwas in der richtung sagt was man dir was man dir so auslegen kann oder haben sie lieber gesagt ja ja ist
Kein problem kann mit rein
Es ist heutzutage so bescheuert ja es alle versuchen in jedem furz was jemand sagt ja entweder was rassistisches zu entdecken was
Diskriminierendes zu entdecken oder sonst was
Muss ich doch nicht so anstellen immer und selbst wenn einer mal was sagt ja selbst wenn einer mal was sagt was ein
Was was einem auf den sack geht ja das ist doch kein weltuntergang
Es ist doch überhaupt nicht schlimm
sind die leute alle so
So wenig überzeugt von von ihren
Sachen da dass sie da immer sofort sofort zweifel kriegen so wenn einer mal was was negatives sagt
Das verstehe ich nicht
Ich verstehe auch nicht diese ganz wie gesagt ich habe es ja voll schon angst vor diese ganze try hat 7 geschichte aus der overwatch
Lieg ich verstehe es nicht warum man das so in so ein akt draus gemacht hat
Vor allem man darf nicht vergessen die haben ja auch schon ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen
Einen akt draus gemacht hat vor allem man darf nicht vergessen die haben ja in der stellungnahme
haben die ja quasi wortwörtlich gesagt dass
exklusiv quasi ein
Ich muss mir die stellungnahme jetzt noch mal angucken dass das ja quasi einen rassistischen ausdruck verwendet hat
Das haben die ja so geschrieben und man muss sich überlegen das grenzt ja schon fast an rufmord im endeffekt in der heutigen zeit so was zu behaupten
Weil hat er nicht hat er hat nicht hat er nicht also ist es hoch fragwürdig ob der was rassistisches erwähnt hat
Ich meine er hat try hat 7 geschrieben also ein offizielles twitch emote mit der 7 dahinter das ist hochgradig fragwürdig ob das rassistisch ist
Ob das rassistisch ist ja
Oder streiger hier ist gar kein streiger sind mystik na das ist mystisch mystik
Der da gerade irgendwie am feld fest hängt aber erstmal den spot hier leer weil dann haben wir fast schon unsere basch im stones voll
Ich habe ja schon mal ein video zu diesem thema gemacht vor ein paar jahren weil ich dazu denke dass das dass ich einfach viel zu viele leute über alles aufregend
Und das beste sind die leute die noch nicht mal selbst betroffen sind die sich dann stellvertretend für andere aufregend das sind die besten
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern vielleicht haben das ein paar leute mit mitverfolgt
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern vielleicht haben das ein paar leute mit mitverfolgt so bei so auch overwatch league da haben ja viele seiten geschrieben
Wie kann es eigentlich sein allein schon dieser dieser transfer im kopf ist wieder total total vier ne da haben haben leute geschrieben ja
Soviel unterschiedliche hellen unter aus unterschiedliche herkunftsländer unterschiedliches geschlecht unterschiedliche hautfarbe und es wäre ganz toll an overwatch
Und wie kann es denn dann sein dass keine frau in der overwatch spiel wobei man sich dann erfragt ok was hat denn bitte schon das charakter des sein in game damit zu tun
Welche leute das spiel auf professionellen level vor der kamera spielen auf der oft quasi auf dem obersten level was es gibt also das habe ich schon nicht wirklich kapiert
Und trotzdem sind dann ganz viele seiten darauf aufgesprungen und haben dann gesagt ja wie kann es sein dass grigori quasi die die also quasi bei
Bei vielen im kopf so als beste overwatch spielerin gilt keine ahnung kann ich nicht beurteilen
Warum die nicht in der overwatch league spielt und haben so viele seiten berichtet sich darüber aufgeregt wie das dann sein kann und dann musste irgendwann
Grigori dies betroffen hat ja musste sagen leute schreibt doch nicht in meinem namen von sachen wo ihr keine ahnung habt so sinngemäß also sprich quasi
Quasi diejenige für die das quasi so so pro sein sollte hat gesagt lasst mich mit dem scheiß in ruhe so weit sind wir mittlerweile schon ich packe es dann
Naja
Aber das ist ein thema da könnte ich mich aufregen das ist mittlerweile so bescheuert du kannst echt nichts mehr sagen
Wir sind echt also wir sind zur zeit in der zeit wo jeder über alles irgendwie offended ist
Aber es ist genau das gleiche ey leute wie sie sich alle aufgeregt haben als unge gesagt hat milch ist giftler meine güte ging sie da alle wieder ab
Und jetzt nicht etwa irgendwie schwach sind oder sonst was du hast dann die einen gehabt die die dann quasi gesagt haben ja selbstverständlich wir werden alle belohnt und das ist gift so ohne sich
Irgendwie mal zu überlegen warum und und du hast die anderen die gesagt die quasi das die die gesagt haben allein schon weil das von unge kommt kann das nichts sein
Er ist auf auf auf endet mich auch das auf endet mich aber auch heftig
Das ist auf auf anstrengt ist auch menschenverachtend muss man mal sagen
Also nicht drei hat 7 ist das problem ist das eigentliche problem
So haben wir es jetzt bald
Und auf 15 deschamps das kann man auf den weg machen
Das kann man auf den weg machen da müssen wir nämlich wieder hier hoch
Und
Wir müssen uns katri stones holen
Ich muss ja sagen die mobs die sind seitdem ich hier 200 ap habe ist das easy mode und ich könnte wenn wenn ich jetzt noch ordentlich barfhut nehmen würde mal meine waffen ordentlich
Socken würde irgendwie neue neue stones mal in mein zeugs reinsocken würde dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich noch mehr und es wäre noch mehr easy mode
Kompleted
Easy klapper
Gibt es irgendein game wo der rank modus nicht für ein arsch ist
Hm
Ja
Ich würde sagen alle worden und die meisten worden und worden games was die starcraft zum beispiel
Da ist da ist das
Problem des teamworks und toxic teammates allein schon mal einfach gar nicht da weil du hast keine teammates
Ähm
Ich würde sagen so so
Sachen die halt nicht in game sind so was wie wie
So was wie facet oder sowas bestimmt auch ganz okay
Na gut for honor for honor ist das rank modus nicht für ein arsch ist das
Man kann es immer verkacken ja man kann es immer verkacken
Aber in der regel hast du einen ganz großen also du hast viele probleme nicht die du also im rank modus in solo games in
In one on one games hast du viele probleme nicht die du in game haben kannst sehr logisch
Ähm
Ich ich ich würde mal sagen die das sowas wie lol und dota 2
Auch nicht übel ist also ich weiß loll wird viel geflamed
Und in loll ist loll war quasi für mich früher immer so der inbegriff von von von toxic ranked
Aber ich finde offer watch hat das alles in den schatten gestellt es gibt es gibt nichts schlimmeres es gibt nichts schlimmeres
Ähm loll hat halt den großen vorteil und ich rede hier nicht aus erfahrung muss ich gleich dazu sagen
Weil ich keine ahnung von loll habe aber loll hat den großen vorteil soweit ich das gelesen habe und auch schon von einigen gehört habe dass
Man noch in einem beschränkten also jetzt vielleicht nicht 100 prozentig aber anders als in offer watch noch den größeren
Einfluss auf den ausgang des games hat wenn man selbst gut spielt
In offer watch kannst du ja nichts machen im endeffekt ja also wenn das wenn das team ungleichmäßig zusammen gewürfelt ist du kannst dir die seele aus dem
Leib dpsen oder supporten oder tanken du hast gelitten du kannst es nicht alleine reißen das geht nicht
Ja du kannst vielleicht wenn du da wenn du irgendwie
Top dps spieler der welt bist ja also wenn jetzt irgendwie hacksal oder was weiß ich oder effekt oder irgendwie einer
Tracer spielt klar kann er da noch ordentlich was raus reißen aber selbst die leute
verzweifeln in ranked camps die sind die sind komplett am verzweifeln und und
quasi mental am auseinanderfallen
Ja csgo würde ich sagen ist das matchmaking auch totaler witz allerdings das nur das in game
Vor allem halt durch die ganze cheater geschichte
Ich glaube da sind aber so sachen wie facet und das was wie heißt das andere für cs was es da noch gibt
Es ist gar nicht so schlecht ranking technisch aber ich glaube allgemein glaube ich dota 2 ist nicht übel
Da muss das ganz gut funktionieren
Was gibt es denn sonst noch für spiele mit ranking system
Dings hier rocket league ist glaube ich ich habe es nie gespielt großartig aber ich glaube rocket league ist e-sport technisch und ranking technisch
Auch nicht schlecht es ist im prinzip fast jedes rank besser als overwatch das ist einfach so in so für ein arsch
Kannst du den unwissen erklären was du da gerade treibst ja kann ich
Ich mache quest ich mache quest für es gibt so einen
Also genau das kann ich euch jetzt mal zeigen
Weil es sind wahrscheinlich noch viele leute genauso große noobs wie ich in der game
Und zwar es gibt vom black spirit eine quest
Die nennt sich
hier
unstoppable thirst for power
Und da kann man sich ein schmuckgegenstand aussuchen entweder ein gürtel
Ich glaube in den gürtel den ring oder den amulett aber da bin ich jetzt nicht ganz sicher und
Da hat da kriegt man dann eine quest
serie
Mit dem man das ding upgraden kann
So und ich habe ich habe ich habe hier schon wir können das gerade mal abkommen ich habe hier schon zwei quests gemacht zum upgraden
Und dieses item kann man kann man upgraden bis pen
und das ist mega op für
pvm also für monsterclocken
Damit kann man siehts hier unten ja auch schon ich habe das ding jetzt quasi auf pri und das hat extra ap against monster 6
Und ich glaube am ende hat das ding plus 15 ap gegen monster wenn man es auf pen hat das heißt wenn man jetzt nicht so das
übertrieben krasse gear hat
kann man richtig schön monster damit grinden weil es mit sicherheit besser ist als das was man hat
Guckt euch mal mein gürtel an ja
mein gürtel das ist
naja
nicht so nicht so das geile teil
Ich habe in velia noch irgendwo ein bisschen theoretisch in velia glaube ich sogar noch einen besseren gürtel liegen lass mal gucken
Was habe ich in velia noch? Ah ne ich habe das alles auf dem bersi drauf
Dann bringt es mir eh nix
Was wollte ich denn machen ich wollte
Bechirms abgeben
Hallo adrian
So gehen wir das mal ab exchange exchange jawoll exchange exchange exchange
Fertig
Sample of bechirms, bechirms wurden gebashed
Naja
So jetzt machen wir
Jetzt machen wir katri
Katri stones waren wir jetzt voll das war hier unten irgendwo
Warum sieht ein black spirit so aus? Ne der black spirit sieht so aus wenn man
Die quest bis nach valencia gemacht hat die main quest muss einfach die main quest weiter machen
Und ich habe die main quest selbst noch nicht abgeschlossen also es könnte sein dass er sogar später noch mal anders aussieht
Weiß ich nicht ich will mit der main quest noch nicht durch
Also muss die main quest machen bis du hier in der in der stadt bist du hier hinten hinkommst
Hier ist dann quasi hier verwandelt er sich dann irgendwann in der main quest
Wofür sind die stones die du da gerade abgegeben hast habe erst vor einer woche mit dem game angefangen also soweit ich weiß nicht
Also erstmal mache ich die natürlich für die für diese komische gürtelquest soweit ich weiß kann man damit jetzt noch schneller xp machen wie vorher
Wir müssen uns jetzt immer welche kaufen kann man gleich mal gucken was da steht
Man kriegt jetzt quasi nicht nur xp fürs monster killen sondern wenn man am richtigen spot ist
Und diesen stein dabei hat dann lädt er sich auf und dann kann man den den stein quasi danach noch mal abgeben
Für noch mal mehr xp da steht hier steht das hier irgendwo catry ruin monsters
Das ist halt wieder mal typisch bdo es steht nicht da was das ding macht
Aber man kriegt mehr xp
Das das das das finde ich an bdo ja auch immer so geil ja steht nirgendwo dran was es macht
So wie viel wie viel 4 stück promen da jetzt da
So und jetzt müssen wir bash im loot noch mal verkaufen reparieren und dann
Gehen wir gehen wir
Catry spot und bashen da weiter
Und dann gehen wir gehen wir catry spot und bashen da weiter
Das ganze chat ist rot hier
Hattest du was und wenn das hat es gerade wegweggescrollt
Hattest du doch dem friseur doch was ne moment ich kann ich kann ich lesen
Hat doch der friseur was hat doch der friseur dich zu bdo bewegt
Ne ne ne ja ja schon hat er hat er
Aber vor allem weil ich jetzt meine tatanda am start habe ich glaube ich muss ja mal ein bisschen quest wenigstens machen
Bisschen mal auskosten das ganze
Pack doch mal lieber xbox one
Aus und spiel mw3 mw3 vor allem mw3 ja klar mw3
mw3
Warte mal nicht verkaufen kann man das sagt das brauchen wir nicht aber so selten
Es lohnt sich eigentlich überhaupt nicht marketplace zu stellen der kack
So
Spasch im zeug weg
Sonst haben wir nämlich wieder platz weil catries droppen wieder ohne ende und machen wir ganz in voll
Value pack geht noch fünf stunden das reicht
Nein nicht nicht basi da auf geht's
Ich finde ich finde es geil ich habe das gefühl die haben den den den run speed vom wizard irgendwie höher gemacht guck mal wie der flitzt
Der flitzt schneller als man fährt
Ich brauche überhaupt kein horse mehr der wizard rennt schneller
Ja das mit den stones habe ich gerade erklärt
Warum sind die warum sind die ancient scrolls nur so wenig? Keine Ahnung wahrscheinlich weil es zu viele marketplace gibt
Wieso
Da sind auch ein bisschen die leute immer dran schuld die das ganze zeug für min preis rein stellen
Alle für max preis rein stellen hätte das problem nicht
Hast du schon mal überlegt einen zweiten kanal aufzumachen für technische sachen in richtung programmieren und so
Nein keine tutorials ja habe ich habe ich habe ich habe ich schon überlegt würde ich auch gerne machen ist problem ich
Ich weiß immer nicht wie sehr ich zu dem kram komme ja es gibt viele sachen die mir so unter den negeln brennt wo ich gern was zu erzählen
Wollt würde auch auch zu dieser ganzen haus automatisierungsgeschichte wo ich hier gerade bei mir am umbauen bin
Gerne was zu erzählen
Auch was es da für unterschiede gibt da wie gesagt gibt da wieder fünf verschiedene funk technologie wieder konkurrieren und so was
Ich weiß halt nicht wie ich irgendwie dazu dazu kommen und es ist doof wenn ich einen neuen channel aufmache und dann gar nichts drauf bringen
So sind ja overwatched
Also ich habe das spiel bis jetzt nur auf steam im shop gesehen dachte das ganz was dachte die ganze zeit es ist noch so ein asia-tippen-crime-mmo
Ist es ja auch
Hast kein t8 horse
Was hältst du vom pass auf exil das beste beste hack and slay oder hack and slash oder action rpg oder wie auch immer das land mag
Pass auf exile dagegen kann alles andere in diesem bereich einpacken
Das ist einfach das beste was es gibt
Es hat einen online modus was
Wo das ganze steht und fällt für mich damit ja also quasi Action RPGs ohne ohne trading und ohne online modus und sowas ist kacke
und diablo 3 ist selbst feind
Selbst feind leather mist geworden das gefällt mir gar nicht mit jedem das sein wem es gefällt
Pass auf exile ist das beste
Wenn man wenn man so auf hack and slay sachen steht
Das hat unglaubliche spiel tiefe total viele bills das ist das beste game
Das hat unglaubliche spiel tiefe total viele bills das ist das beste game wenn man auch so was steht
Mein wasser grill geht mir auf den keks macht so komische geräusche
Wie das warum ist das handeln nicht offiziell du kannst doch in game gehen und sage hier zelle das suche das kannst du doch machen
Zumindest konnte man das noch als ich als ich pass auf exile gespielt habe
Kannst sagen hier tausche tausche so und so viel ob teile zu orb und das war kein ding ich meine ich meine ja nicht echt geld
Ich meine ich meine irgendwie nicht ebay echt geld auktionshaus oder sowas ich meine in game trading also sprich
Ein item gegen andere item crafting zutaten gegen andere crafting zutaten also das im prinzip das was bdo nicht hat
Wobei ich finde in bdo ist das an sich gut umgesetzt und ich kann verstehen warum es das hier nicht gibt
Aus diesem grund gibt es halt hier auch keine china farmer und gold seller weil es einfach nicht funktioniert
Und ich glaube fast dass man mmos gar nicht mehr anders machen kann
Ohne also wenn man wenn man wenn man china wenn man china farmer und gold seller und item seiten und so
Quasi nicht im spiel haben will bleibt dann glaube ich gar nicht viel anders war übrig
Außer das trading und handelssystem so zu machen wie in bdo
Also mit mir fällt nichts anderes ein
Alles wo mein spieler erlauben würde wirklich gold gegen items und sonst was zu train
Also in game mit trading fenster so nach dem otto man trifft sich und hier gebe die gold gibt es mir items sobald das möglich ist
Öffnet es ja auch tür und tor für china farmer seiten
Und wenn du es halt so machst wie bdo hast du das problem mit china farmer seiten nicht auch wenn ich an sich in dem mmo
So diesen handel aspekt von spieler zu spieler immer immer wichtig finde
Ich kann verstehen warum es es nicht gibt und mir fällt keine es mir fällt nicht anderes ein wie man das machen sollte
Dass man nicht automatisch china farmer in game hat
Außer es halt so zu machen wie spd o macht
Er war macht glaube ich ein bisschen anders und da klappt es halt auch nicht
Versucht jetzt ja dass du mit mit in game gold irgendwie spielzeit oder so kaufen kannst
Aber ich glaube nicht also ihr könnt mir das ja mal erzählen falls einer von euch wo spielt
Ich glaube nicht dass dadurch dass es dadurch weniger china farmer und und so sachen gibt gold gold china seiten für wo
Ich gehe mal davon aus das ist da wie wie eh und je
Oder
Oder high trade ich habe den doch letzten schon gebannt warum ist er wieder da
Piss dich alde high trade high trade bot gleich bannen
Ich habe den noch letzten schon gebannt ich habe mir glaube nur gekickt gleich weg damit
Brauchen wir nicht
Gleich weg schrecken
Also mr. Mcbong das verstehe ich jetzt nicht ggg ist doch kleinen hier games oder
Das ist doch der hersteller von poe
Und die haben doch in ihr game ein trading chat und in game handeln eingebaut
Wie kann es sein dass sie es nur dulden wenn die sich doch explizit eingebaut haben in game
Oder verstehe ich jetzt nicht was du meinst
So weiter jetzt wir waren hier noch mal eine gute spot hier durch irgendwo na ja genau hier durch
Ach poe trade
Ach du meinst eine seite die poe trade heißt ich habe jetzt aber da habe ich das falsch verstanden ich habe verstanden trading in pass of exile
Ich wusste nicht dass es eine seite gibt die poe trade heißt
Ich dachte es ging halt um trading in pass of exile
Ja zwischenmenschliche kommunikation ist manchmal nicht so einfach
Lull Lull immer L sagen Lull
Jawoll der high traded bot schön wenn irgendwie sowas reingehört mir gleich spannen
Ich finde es ja auch ich finde es ja auch geiler dass man bots programmieren darf von twitch seite die in channels rumjoin und spammen
Ohne dass man das gelähmigen muss
Auch geil immerhin klar im prinzip kann er twitch nicht viel dagegen machen
Du kannst ja auch einfach nicht alles normaler ach das der hält mir jetzt zu viel aus und das item brauche ich erinnert
Ich finde es ja auch ich finde es ja auch geil dass man bots programmieren darf von twitch seite die in channels rumjoin und spammen
Auch geil immerhin klar im prinzip kann er twitch nicht viel Colombia
Ich muss euch jetzt mal was fragen, was was ihr wahrscheinlich nicht erwartet hättet von mir zu hören, aber hat jemand von euch die letzten paar Dragon Ball Superfolgen geguckt?
Ich hab nämlich aus irgendwelchen Gründen, ich war ja nie so der großartige Dragon Ball Fan, aber ich hab die letzten paar Folgen geguckt, davor gar nicht ja, also vor ein paar Jahren mal, aber super hab ich nie geguckt
Und ich fand das echt nice, die letzten paar Folgen, das ist halt so typisch Brain Dead, ja, so typisches Dragon Ball Brain Dead, wir schlagen aufeinander rum und schreien dabei 20 Minuten und es passiert eigentlich nichts
Aber ich fand das echt nice, das hab ich dann abends Tablet, hab ich ein Bad Tablet nochmal angemacht, nämlich Folge geguckt, das ist so richtig Brain AFK Zeug
Und ich bin jetzt echt schon ein bisschen irgendwie so ein bisschen traurig, dass das vorbei ist, weil ich hab mich daran gewöhnt, dass ich mir jetzt immer mal so eine Folge abends noch geben kann
Ich überleg mir fast schon den neuen Film anzugucken, weil da ein Boss kommt
Und hier muss man aufpassen, hier ist irgendwie so ein super, super fetter World Boss, oder heißt der nicht World Boss, in dem Spiel halt irgendwie so ein Gatekeeper heißt das genau
Alter Wubbler bewegt mich
Hatte gerade Katzen Werbung, war das Zufall, ja, ich hab keinen Einfluss auf die Werbung
Null Einfluss
Da hast du dir wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Katzensachen vorher angeguckt
Das, wer auch welches Affiliate Netzwerk auch immer dafür zuständig ist, der Meinung war, du musst dir jetzt Katzen Zeug angucken
Ist ja auch schon wieder einer
Was, der hat sich aber weg teleportiert
Alles down, vielleicht muss ich den Channel wechseln
Ja Elmo, ich kann dazu gar nichts sagen, außer die letzten paar Folgen, die waren echt nice, also richtig brain der Zeug, du musst halt null konzentrieren
Als was arbeitest du, wir haben uns letztens eine schöne Bezeichnung im Stream dafür ausgedacht, ich bin Head, oh fuck, ich hab's vergessen, Head of, Head of, oh fuck, ich hab's vergessen
Da ist klein richtig, richtig pro
Ich kümmere mich um, ich kann mir eh, das ist immer schwierig zu erklären, um Versionsverwaltung von Software
So, das umschreibt es glaube ich am besten
Ja, ich kann mein Gear zeigen, ist jetzt seit gestern, richtig OP
Gestern hier Ted Dunder am Start, easy
Und ihr wollt nicht wissen wie, ne, ich hab natürlich mal wieder nicht selbst enchantet, sondern der Fabian, wenn wie auch sonst, ich weiß nicht
Wie gesagt, ich bin der übelste Noob in dem Game, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie man das ordentlich macht, ist ja auch so eine Wissenschaft für sich
Und ihr wollt nicht wissen, wir haben gestern fast alles wieder gewornschottet, wir haben fast nichts gefailed, das war wieder übelster RNG-Luck
Also ich glaub, wir haben für die Ted Dunder, wir haben erstmal, also ihr müsst ja wissen, ich hab ja jetzt 3 oder 4 Monate AFK, Daily Rewards und solche eingesammelt
Ich spiel ja quasi gar nicht, also ich spiel ja kaum, ich hab ja auch keine Playtime so richtig
Und ich hab jetzt die letzten paar Monate, hab ich einfach Daily Rewards und alles eingesackt
Also ich hatte jetzt ordentlich Geld und Materialien, also wir haben gestern ungefähr mit
Also ich hatte da, ich hatte am Anfang, wo wir angefangen haben zu enchanten gestern, hatte ich um die 500 Millionen Gold und halt massig, massig Stones
Und am Ende hatte ich dann noch irgendwie 200 Millionen Gold und keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal so, irgendwie die Hälfte der Stones weg, irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh
Und davon haben wir gestern gemacht, quasi die Dande von 0 auf Ted, also wirklich komplett von 0, es war nicht Pri oder so, es war 0
Also wir haben gestern die Dande Box aufgemacht quasi, dann haben wir einen zweiten Crescent Guardian Ring gemacht, auch von 0
Und von 0 noch die zwei Ohrringe und es ist alles irgendwie mit 250 Millionen Gold und ein paar Steinen, so easy
Und was man aber nicht vergessen darf, natürlich noch die ganzen Quest Rewards, die ich hatte, da waren ja auch Failstacks und diese Valk Geschichten und sowas drinne
Also das hat natürlich auch gut geholfen, drei bis vier Monate Daily Rewards und sowas
Aber das war mega luck, ultraluck war das
Deswegen mache ich jetzt diese komische Gürtel Quest, da ich dann noch einen richtig geilen Gürtel habe für PvM
Weil nochmal plus 15 AP von dem Gürtel, das geht ab, kann ich dann mit Fabian zusammen irgendwie OP, OP Spots grinden
Wie viel Stromrechnung gefarmt, nee ich hab nicht gefarmt nebenher, gar nicht, ich hab gar nicht AFK gefarmt, ich hab einfach nur einmal am Tag eingeloggt oder am Wochenende mal eine Stunde
Dass ich halt doppelt Daily Rewards krieg, übrigens für alle die das nicht wissen, ich hab das auch lange nicht gecheckt
Man kann, die Daily Rewards die man kriegt, wenn man was verpasst hat, ich hab nämlich diesen Monat, da war ich faul, kriegt man am Wochenende zwei
Ich hab jetzt mal ein bisschen aufgeholt, dass ich wenigstens das Siegel hier noch krieg, diesen Monat
Und dann kaufe ich mir nächsten Monat noch von meinen Seals, weil ich hab, dann hab ich 100 Shakator Seals gesammelt
Dann kaufe ich mir noch einen Duo Ogaring und dann bin ich absolut OP-Wesart, mit quasi Null Spielzeit
Null nicht, das war ja früher mal ein AFK-Fisch-Char hier, aber mit fast Null
Gehts?
Ist alles weg, glaube ich switch jetzt mal
Ja, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab, schreibts einfach noch mal in den Chat
Endlich streamt er, ich hab lange nicht gestreamt, das stimmt
Und ich muss ehrlich gestehen, ich hab ja heute auch noch gestreamt oder ich hab heute auch noch streamen angemacht, weil das so langweilig ist alleine BDO-Quests zu machen
Also eins ist definitiv nicht die Stärke von BDO und das sind spannende Quests
Da muss man aber, der Fan ist halber sagen, spannende Quests haben die wenigsten MMOs in der Masse zu bieten
Also viele MMOs haben natürlich spannende Main-Quests oder ab und zu mal spannende Side-Quests oder Quests, die nicht total kacke sind
Aber 90% oder 95% aller MMO-Quests in allen MMOs sind einfach scheiße
Die sind einfach totaler Mist, das sind die üblichen Quests und BDO verschleiert das halt noch nicht mal
Die machen da auch gar keinen großen Akt drum herum, die sagen halt einfach, hey, kille 500 Monster, kille 500 Monster, kille 500 Monster, kille 500 Monster
In WoW wärst du dann zum Beispiel noch dreimal über die Worldmap gelaufen zwischendurch
Weißt du, dreimal über die Worldmap gelaufen, um dann irgendwie einem NPC zu sagen, oh Hilfe, die Orks greifen an
Und dann irgendwie den Wachen ihre Ration zu bringen, danach dann irgendwie dem Truppenkommandeur Bescheid zu sagen
Dann irgendwie den Verletzten noch, ihr kennt MMO-Quests, ihr kennt MMO-Quests
Da finde ich das in BDO sogar fast schon angenehm, die verschleiern das halt gar nicht, die sagen einfach, hey, kille 500 Monster, fertig, next
Ich glaube für MMO-Quests, da könnte man, das haben die bestimmt, auch so Quest-Generator programmieren, weil die Quests, die sind wirklich nicht sonderlich durchdacht
Das ist halt so bring a random, kill a random, hole random, drücke 5x random, so, ist halt MMO-Quests
Was, Leute, was war die schlimmste MMO-Quest, die ihr jemals gemacht habt?
Da muss ich jetzt auch mal kurz überlangen, was war die schlimmste MMO-Quest?
Ich glaube, ja, also die schlimmste MMO-Quest war die, ähm
Ja, die schlimmste MMO-Quest war in Dark Edge of Camelot die alte Clary-Epic-Quest
Da hast du irgendwie 3 Tage für gebraucht, weil du ohne Speed 5x quer durchs Land rennen musstest und du als Clary noch nicht mal die Mobs alleine killen konntest
Das war die schlimmste, die schlimmste Quest in allen MMOs
Die alte Clary-Epic-Quest in Dark Edge
Die war auch absichtlich so gemacht
Also die haben das noch nicht mal versucht irgendwie dir schön zu reden, so nach dem Motto, ja, wir haben jetzt ein paar schön geschriebene Quest-Texte oder irgendwie Spannung oder sonst was
Nee, das war einfach ganz simples, Renne von Camelot nach an Arsch der Welt, Renne vom Arsch der Welt irgendwo anders hin
Die schlimmste, die ich jetzt gerade mache, nee, die ist nicht schlimm
Das ist nichts, das ist nichts gegen die Clary-Epic-Quest
Hier kannst du wenigstens schon an einem Spot stehen, die Mobs spaschen und dann bist du fertig
Guck mal, wir sind schon zur Hälfte durch
Nee, zu einem Drittel sind wir durch
Und ich könnte mir bei Gelegenheit auch mal wieder Pots kaufen
Ich glaube, ich habe einmal Baschem zu viel gekauft
Egal, who cares
In WoW-Gewichte tragen, wo man damit 20% Movement-Speed rumhampelt
Ja, solche Quests sind auch immer schlimm
Es gibt, genau, das ist ja auch sehr beliebt, den MMO-Quest, bringe 15 Wasserfässer oder sowas
Oder bringe den Truppen an der Front 15 Wasserfässer
Und dann musst du dann irgendwie von in einem Dorf 10 Minuten laufen mit Movement-Speed-Debuff, weil du halt Wasserfässer hast
Das ist halt extremer Resident-Sleeper, so Quests
Wo wir gerade vorher beim Thema Hausautomatisierung waren, hat jemand von euch Smart-Home-Geräte?
Also egal was, sei es jetzt irgendwelche Fenstersensor und Thermostate
Luftentfeuchtungsdinger oder was auch immer
Habt ihr da irgendwas?
Und wie ich würde interessieren, was?
Weil wie gesagt, ich bin ja gerade noch so ein bisschen am rumgucken
Ja, C9, Nobody, das wär so
Das ist auch immer bei MMOs so geil
Es gibt ja MMOs, die wollen dir dann quasi erzählen, du bist der größte Held aller Zeiten
Was ich bei einem MMO für Storytelling, ehrlich gesagt, eh einen blöden Ansatz finde
Also man sollte eigentlich auch so einen MMO-Charakter nie irgendwie super krassen Held machen
Weil es saumäßig schwierig in der Welt zu erklären ist
Weil wie willst du beispielsweise realistisch erklären, dass quasi alle 50.000 Spieler die größten Helden aller Zeiten sind?
Das ergibt ja keinen Sinn
Aber kann ja nicht jeder Held der größten Held aller Zeiten sein
Das heißt, wenn das MMOs versuchen in ihrer Story zu erzählen, dann klappt das überhaupt nicht
Deswegen finde ich es besser, als bei Quests, keine Ahnung, von BDO-Quests habe ich mir noch nie die Story durchgelesen
Aber ich finde es besser, wenn Games quasi, also MMOs, die Quests halt so aufbauen
Du bist halt irgendwie einfach auch nur irgendjemand, der in dieser Welt lebt und versucht, über die Runden zu kommen, halt irgendwie Monster bashed
Aber halt nicht der krasseste Held aller Zeiten, der danach Wasser tragen muss
So, weißt du, ich hatte auch gerade einer im Chat geschrieben, ich bin der größte Held aller Zeiten
In WoW habe ich die Welt gerettet, den stärksten Boss besiegt, die halbe Welt huldig mir
Und danach werde ich gefragt, ob ich jetzt nicht einfach nochmal nebenbei kurz mal 5 Wasser einmal tragen kann
Da passen halt MMO-Quests nicht so ganz, ne?
Das ist halt doof
Deswegen finde ich es viel besser, wenn man die Quests in MMOs so aufbaut, dass man halt nicht der Geilste ist
Zum Glück hat sich der Typ hier verpisst
Was der Fischer inwieweit hat Blizzard in WoW Crichton von Diablo da jetzt eingefügt, das habe ich jetzt noch nicht gehört
Also das Einzige, was ich von WoW in letzter Zeit gehört habe, ist, dass es jetzt ein neues Addon gibt
Und das Einzige, was ich von diesem Addon gesehen habe, ist das Intro Cinematic
Und das ist extrem geil, das ist so geil, ich glaube, das ist das geilste Cinematic, was Blizzard hier gemacht hat
Habt ihr das gesehen? Kennt ihr das neue WoW Intro Cinematic?
Das ist eines der besten Sachen, die Blizzard hier jeder animiert und gemacht hat
Find ich übertrieben geil, das können sie echt
Also eines muss ich sagen, Blizzard kann Zwischen-Sequenzen-Grammy machen
Ja, das stimmt, Trailer konnte Blizzard schon immer
Ob das Gamebus taugt, keine Ahnung, aber der Trailer ist geil
Was ist eigentlich generell deine Meinung über WoW?
Ich, wie gesagt, ich kann das auch nur immer auf das als Grundlage nehmen, was ich irgendwie lese und höre, weil ich spiele WoW nicht
Ich habe WoW mal ganz kurz zur Release gespielt, aber ich habe jahrelang Dark Edge of Camelot gespielt
Und das war halt zu der Zeit, wo WoW auch noch richtig im Hype war
Also diese riesen WoW Hype-Welle habe ich nie aktiv mitgespielt
Deswegen habe ich auch keinen nostalgischen Blick auf WoW
Für mich ist WoW als Außenstehender betrachtet ein MMO, dem du im Kern anmerkst, dass es zehn Jahre alt ist
Oder so ungefähr, ich weiß gar nicht, wie alt es genau ist, wo halt sehr viel Wert mittlerweile drauf gelegt wird, es allen irgendwie recht zu machen
Das ist so, wie ich war, so von dem, was ich lese und was ich sehe als Außenstehender im MMO
Dass Blizzard sehr viel Wert darauf legt, es allen Leuten irgendwie recht zu machen und da wohl schon seit einer Weile nichts halbes und nichts ganzes mehr bei rauskommt
Weil es ist in MMOs einfach so, manche Sachen müssen schwer sein
Es muss Content geben, der für einige Leute unerreichbar ist, muss es geben, also aus meiner Sicht muss es das geben
Wisst ihr, das ist einfach so, dass irgendwie, früher war das zumindest in MMOs so
Wisst ihr, so die richtig krassen PvP Leute, die richtig krassen PvM-Guilden und so, die hatten teilweise schon so richtig so einen Legendenstatus
Du wusstest halt, das ist dann ein Boss, ein Raid, eine Instanz oder, ich bin auch kein Fan von dieser ganzen Instanzierungssache, muss ich auch nochmal sagen
Wo du wusstest, du wirst das als Normalsterblicher vielleicht mal sehen irgendwann, aber niemals schaffen oder wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal sehen
Und du hast dann quasi zu den Leuten aufgeguckt, die das geschaffen haben und hast dir gesagt, boah ey, das boah sind die krass, vielleicht komme ich irgendwann auch mal in so eine geile Gilde und so was
Das hast du halt gar nicht mehr, wenn du im Prinzip eh alles irgendwie hinkriegst und der Highend Content, den du nicht erreichen kannst, ist halt quasi nur Recycle, der normaler Content ist
Was genau ist Black Desert Online, ein MMO, mit viel Gekreinde, was auf den ersten Blick nicht komplex aussieht, aber saumäßig komplex ist
Und ich eigentlich überhaupt keine Ahnung von dem Game hab und der übelste Loot bin, aber gutes Gier, das muss sein, gutes Gier muss sein, weil man einfach ein bisschen Arangela Cut
Ja Ehex, genau so ist es, es haben sich früher um MMOs irgendwie so Legenden auch gebildet, weil es irgendwie Sachen gab, die hat nicht jeder hingekriegt und das war voll mystisch irgendwie auch
Und heute wird halt drauf geguckt, dass du nichts einbaust, was nicht irgendwie auch der normale Spieler packen könnte, ich mein es ist aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht vom Hersteller fest, versteh ich irgendwie ja
Warum sollte man viel Mühe und Energie in Content stecken, den nur 5% der Spieler sehen bis zum Schluss, ich kann das schon irgendwie verstehen, aber das nimmt im Spiel so die Seele auf, wenn du weißt da ist eigentlich gar nichts mehr
Weil es ist ja nichts irgendwie spannender, was so ein bisschen mysteriös und unklar ist, das macht es ja für die Leute spannend, wenn für dich alles direkt sichtbar ist, alles direkt klar ist und es überhaupt kein Geheimnis mehr darum ist
Ich mein früher wurde sich da bei Games oder bei MMOs Sachen erzählt, die überhaupt nicht stimmen irgendwie, also wisst ihr so nach dem Motto, ja am Ende dieses ultra schweren Bosses passiert dann das und das
Was einfach nur blödsinnig war, weil es wusste keiner was da passiert, aber wenn es halt alles so offensichtlich ist, quasi jeder voll Bob das hinkriegt, dann ist das auch irgendwie langweilig
Herr Krachten, ja auf der Gamescom, klar, wurde ich schon erkannt, auf der Rolltreppe, das weiß ich noch, nicht nur einmal, aber auf der Rolltreppe, das weiß ich noch, das war lustig auf der Rolltreppe
Weil wir waren bei Battlefield Hardline war das damals, bei EA oben, zu dem Zeitpunkt als EA noch mit einem reden wollte, obwohl man was mit G2A gemacht hat
Da waren wir bei Battlefield Hardline drin, da haben wir gespielt, da waren wir bei Battlefield Hardline, falls sich da noch irgendjemand dran erinnert, ich war in Battlefield Hardline
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal was, pass mal auf, das muss ich euch jetzt zeigen, wartet mal, pass mal auf Battlefield Hardline
Wo geht das hier, äh äh äh äh, Capture, Capture, Capture, Display, Display Capture, pass mal auf, Battlefield Hardline
Boah, geil oder, die Spielerzahlen, was ist das, 405, 405, VTF, ich wusste gar nicht, ich wusste gar nicht, ob es für die PS4 überhaupt noch gibt das Game
405, das ist der Witz, ja, so mal zum Vergleich, BF4, immerhin, und jetzt BF1, das ist übrigens auch geil, ne, guckt euch das mal an
22 für das letzte Battlefield und quasi mehr als die Hälfte für das vorletzte, weiß ich grad gar nicht, Hardline, One und Bald, ups, äh, Display Capture
Äh, ne, ja, Battlefield 3 hat mehr als Hardline, ja, ja, Battlefield 3, Battlefield 3 hat 5000 oder sowas, ich muss mal kurz gucken, aber BF3 Stats, äh, die Statsite ist kaputt, die geht nicht mehr
Ah doch, ne, hier, 3000, 3200, PS3 2200, äh, also irgendwie 7000, irgendwie 7000 auf allen Plattformen zusammen noch, Battlefield 3, das ist halt auch ein geiles Game
Hardline hat so gefailt, Hardline, das war so, naja, zumindest haben wir auf der Gamescom diesen, diesen, was sie damals als Competitive Modus verkaufen wollten, es gab doch in Battlefield Hardline, falls sich da noch jemand dran erinnert
gab es so dieses, wir verteidigen ein, ein Haus, also so ein bisschen im Endeffekt, ein bisschen im Endeffekt wie Rainbow Six, bloß schlechter, da gab es so ein Modus wie, wir verteidigen ein, ein Haus, halt auf Battlefield Maps, es war nicht immer ein Haus, aber es war immer irgendwas Zentrales
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie der Modus hieß in Battlefield Hardline, ja und den haben wir damals auf der Gamescom gespielt und da war jemand dabei, der hat sich dann auf der Rolltreppe so angeschlichen irgendwie und hat, hat halt gemeint er erkennt, das habe ich mir gemerkt, angestellt kam er auf der Rolltreppe
da kam er auf der Rolltreppe
so, haben wir's jetzt bald, ne
ist der erste, ist der erste zweite Stein
Desert Naga ist wahrscheinlich wieder komplett überrannt
mit Leuten
Ich hab irgendwo mal gelesen, Desert Naga gibt's ergeblich als beste XP.
Bei Desert Naga mach ich dann auch mal einen Daily XP Buff an.
Hardline wäre wohl ohne Battle für die im Namen etwas besser gefahren, ich weiß nicht.
Ich fand Hardline war irgendwie einfach unstimmig.
Ich fand Hardline war irgendwie unstimmig. Mir hat auch Rush gefehlt.
Rush hat mir extrem gefehlt und ich glaube, das hätte in Hardline auch gut funktionieren.
Ich mein, guck mal, in Hardline gab's doch diesen Bunker-Hop-Modus.
Warum könnte man das nicht als Rushrap machen? So ein bisschen wie Payday.
Das hätte sich doch so gut geeignet. Du hättest vorher irgendwas einnehmen müssen, dann noch was, dann noch was, dann noch was.
Und dann am Ende hättest du irgendwie den Save geknackt und dann wirst du abgehauen.
Irgendwie sowas. Das hätte man auch wunderbar als Rush-Runde machen können.
Oder zumindest als sowas ähnliches wie Rush und nicht dieses komische Ding, wo du in Spawn reinballern konntest sogar noch.
Nee, das war verkackt. Und Battlefield V wird auch verkackt, ich sag's euch.
Ich prophezeihe das jetzt schon mal.
Battlefield V, wie auch immer. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie EA gerne hätte, dass man das nennt.
Battlefield V. Battlefield Römisch V.
Battlefield V wie?
Battlefield V, keine Ahnung, ich bin mal gespannt. Battlefield Veritas, keine Ahnung. Wer weiß, was denen da einfällt.
Allerdings ist die Benahmung von Battlefield so krass im Arsch mittlerweile. Es ist eigentlich egal.
Eigentlich sollten sie, also meiner Meinung nach, sollten sie die Normierung komplett weglassen mittlerweile.
Weil es ist einfach kaputt.
Es ist kaputt seit Battlefield 1. Die Nummerierung ist im Arsch.
Es checkt doch keiner mehr, dass nach vier ein unbenummerter Teil kommt.
Danach eins und danach fünf, was allerdings der Nachfolger von eins ist.
What?
Wer soll das verstehen?
Das versteht man schon schwierig, wenn man das Ganze mitverfolgt.
Aber wenn man da keine Ahnung von hat, das checkt, das verstehst du doch nicht.
Das checkt, das kannst du gar nicht verstehen als Ausstehender.
Versetzt euch doch mal einen 0815 Casual Typ rein, der gerne Battlefield spielt.
Allerdings ist er wirklich so komplett casual. Ich kaufe mir ein neues Battlefield, spiele das ab und zu ein bisschen.
Was weiß ich, zweimal die Woche abends, so eine Stunde.
Würdet ihr das verstehen?
An dem seiner Stelle?
Warum das jetzt fünf heißt?
Oder voraussichtlich fünf?
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, dass Battlefield V richtig sein wird.
So, oh, Loot. Ich wusste gleich mal, sehr innen.
Ich hätte mich am meisten über Bad Company 3 gefreut, sagt der letzte Pilger.
Ja, ich mich auch.
Geht mir genauso.
Geht mir ganz genauso.
Let's go.
Geht mir genauso. Geht mir ganz genauso.
Bad Company 3 beste.
Mal schauen, ob es beste wird.
Ich sollte die Benamung komplett weglassen.
Die sollten sich einen Untertitel überlegen.
Und gut ist.
Irgendwas Passendes.
Sollen sie es halt...
Sie könnten...
Wisst ihr, was cool wäre?
Was so ein bisschen auch...
Was allerdings ein gewisses Maß von Kreativität von EA bzw. DICE verlangen würde.
Man könnte die Numerierung der Battlefield-Teile offiziell aufgeben.
Man schreibt nicht mehr rein.
Fünf oder eins.
Aber man behält die Numerierung immer.
Behält die Numerierung in irgendeiner Form angedeutet bei.
Zum Beispiel so was wie Battlefield Victory.
Ich gebe zu, das ist kein tolles Beispiel.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Versteht ihr, wie ich das meine?
Also man benennt die Dinge jetzt nicht mehr Battlefield 5, 6, 7, 8.
Sondern man benennt sie halt...
Man gibt ihnen irgendeinen Namen.
Allerdings, dass die Numerierung noch weiterhin andeutet.
Das würde aber ein gewisses Maß an Kreativität erfordern.
Dass man sich da jedes Mal was Gutes einfallen lässt.
Weiß nicht, ob sie da Bock drauf haben.
Man könnte es ja wirklich Battlefield Victory oder so nennen.
Da hast du dann 5.
Obwohl es keine Zahlen mehr drin ist.
Bei Battlefield 6 müsste man sich halt was anderes überlegen.
Wie man die 6 da einbauen kann oder 6 zu nennen.
So könnte man das machen.
Ich glaube, auf alles, was irgendwie ein bisschen...
...die Hinleistung erfordert, haben die immer so viel Bock.
Wo man sich Gedanken machen muss, das ist...
...overrated, outdated, debated.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Man macht Schema F.
Für sich ist es neu bei Battlefield.
Jemand, der noch 5 schreibt.
5.
Das wären dann die gleichen, die Gears of War übersetzt haben.
Oder Halo.
Halo.
Oder SC.
Was gab es denn da noch?
Es gab Halo 3, es gab Halo Ozt.
Ozt Tor.
Reach, Reach war das.
Genau, Reach.
Wo sie in der deutschen Übersetzung permanent gesagt haben.
In dein Gesicht.
Also wer das übersetzt hat.
Die übersetzen Battlefield 5 auch mit 5.
V5.
Ups.
Ich muss sagen, mit 200 AP ist es jetzt viel entspannter hier.
Ich muss kaum noch hingucken.
Was macht man?
Oh, ich muss meine Daily Eier-Quest noch machen.
Das habe ich nicht vergessen.
Daily Eier-Quest.
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch einmal kurz verkaufen gehen.
Zwischendurch habe ich auch keinen Gaul dabei.
Wir müssen einmal noch verkaufen gehen, dass ich die anderen beiden voll machen kann.
Also den können wir noch voll machen.
Danach ist Impf dicht.
Dann rennen wir schnell nach Altinova runter.
Das ist ja nicht so weit.
Dahin.
Nee, reicht doch.
Hier ist aber kein Bault.
Ja, wir müssen dahin rennen und dann wieder nach hoch.
Aber das geht.
Der Wizard ist ja mittlerweile sehr zackig.
Guck durch das Bahn hier.
Der flitzt.
Kann auch teleporten zwischendurch.
Da sind wir 0,0x da und wieder zurück.
Wie lange machst du noch?
Ich hatte eigentlich vor, ich mache die Gürtel-Quest fertig.
Das dauert noch.
Also ich muss jetzt noch...
Sagen wir mal so.
Ich muss noch 1200 Catrice machen.
Oder?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Dann können wir noch 1000 Catrice machen, 2000 Nagas machen, 2000 Fogens machen.
Das dauert noch ein bisschen.
Das bin ich noch ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Black Desert.
Alonzo, bist du in guter Gesellschaft?
Ich auch nicht.
Lol.
Und ich meine das ernst, ne?
Wenn es alle mal zerstört hier.
18 Fischer, gibt es Brigitte jetzt schon auf Liveserver?
Ach, gibt es schon.
Okay.
Ich habe nicht vorhin nichts.
Hat seine Overwatch zu spielen.
Das tiltet mich immer zu sehr.
Overwatch schwenkt.
Das geht nicht.
Halt schnell aus.
Fangen wir das noch?
Ja.
Dafür sollte das Inf noch reichen.
Es rockelt.
Okay.
Hat einer von euch Far Cry 5 gespielt?
Ich habe mir nämlich, ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich mir das holen soll.
Aber irgendwie, ihr könnt mich ja, also wer es gespielt hat, vielleicht liege ich da auch falsch.
Aber ich habe mir bei Far Cry 4 schon gedacht, das war nicht schlecht.
Aber noch mal das gleiche Game können sie nicht bringen.
Und so wie es aussieht, haben sie jetzt halt noch mal exakt das gleiche Game gebracht.
Und eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock auf ein neues Far Cry 3.
Weil im Endeffekt war Far Cry 4 quasi ein Far Cry 3 in den Bergen.
Und Far Cry 5 sieht auch aus wie ein Far Cry 3 jetzt halt auch wieder nicht ganz so sehr in den Bergen.
Okay.
Es ist nur Recycling.
Dann hole ich es mir nicht.
Warum hat eigentlich dieser komische Oberfahrer, der auf den Coverbilder drauf ist von Far Cry 5,
warum hat er eigentlich Gunner Optics an?
Wird das in der Story erklärt?
Also den hier, ne?
Den da meine ich.
Wo ist er denn?
Da.
Guck mal.
Guck mal den da.
Warum hat er, warum hat er Gunner Optics an?
Seht ihr das?
Ich würde das gerne, ich würde das gerne vergrößern.
Warum hat er Gunner Optics an?
Steh ich nicht.
Das ist doch die MLG Quickscope-Brille.
Kann er da besser beten damit?
360-Betting.
360-Prayer.
Oder sollte er einfach nur geil aussehen oder einfach nur cool aussehen?
Mussten sie ihm irgendwas anziehen, dass man ihn wieder erkennt?
Ja, Mr. BC Bong ist wirklich so.
Also viele Games kann man, wenn sie rauskommen, erst mal links liegen lassen und dann spielen, wenn sie ein bisschen billiger sind.
Das ist gar kein so schlechter Ansatz.
Es kommt ja auch allgemein relativ viel raus.
Letztes Jahr kam ja ziemlich viel.
Und es ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich hab' früher auch auf den Fehler gemacht.
Also aus meiner Sicht Fehler.
Dass ich bei Steam, dass ich dachte, oh geil, das Game kommt raus.
Hab' ich mir gekauft und dann hab' ich's nie gespielt.
Irgendwann, irgendwann mal zwei Jahre später oder so.
Aber am besten eigentlich, man kauft sich nicht direkt zur Release, sondern kauft sich wirklich dann, wenn man spielen will.
Weil ich hab' im Prinzip so viel Kohle zum Fenster rausgeschmissen, weil ich die Games direkt gekauft hab' und nie gespielt hab'.
Hätte ich gewartet und dann hätte ich's irgendwann bei einem Sale gesehen, gekauft und gespielt.
Dann hätte ich dann anstatt 60 Euro für die super krasse Digital Deluxe Edition oder was es dann auch immer von den Games gibt,
hätte ich anstatt 60 Euro oder 10 Euro bezahlt. Also eigentlich total dumm, das Zeug gleich zu kaufen.
Wenn man, es sei denn man will's wirklich sofort spielen, dann ja.
Aber ansonsten einfach nur kaufen, um's dann zu spielen.
Und ich kenn's halt von mir, ich spiel's halt nicht.
Ich kauf' mir irgendwas und dann legt es in meiner Steam-Bibliothek erstmal rum.
Nein, wenn man jetzt jemand ist, das sich ein Game kauft und das dann direkt spielt dann, und man das spielt,
dann spricht ja nichts dagegen, das direkt zu kaufen bei Release.
Was spielst du derzeit so?
Äh, nix eigentlich.
Nix großartig. Ich spiele Heim-Automatisierung einrichten.
Das ist frisst Zeit genug.
Ging der Fortnite-Hype komplett an mir vorbei.
Der ganze Battle Royale-Hype ging, was heißt ging, der ging nicht an mir vorbei.
Ich hab den schon mitgekriegt, aber es ist nicht so meins.
Aber was ich witzig fand, damals als Fortnite rausgekommen ist,
als es quasi als Puppe-Konkurrent gestartet ist.
Damals hab ich schon im Video gesagt, Leute, Fortnite wird das neue Nummer 1 Battle Royale-Game.
Ich find, es war so offensichtlich.
Und jetzt ein paar Monate später ist es so. Bam! Prediction.
Ich mein, wenn man sich Puppe angeguckt hat, ich kann mir das so richtig vorstellen,
wie das bei Epic Games gelaufen ist.
Die haben gesehen, Puppe kommt raus, haben gesagt, Lull, was ein Kack-Game.
Was ja auch technisch gesehen war und ist.
Und haben gesagt, das spielt doch keiner, das spielt doch keiner.
Komm hier, wir machen weiter an dem Tournament, Fortnite, wie es ursprünglich war.
Und was haben die sonst noch gemacht? Paragon? Nee.
Fuck, wie hieß das? Das MOBA von Epic Games.
Ja, wir machen das weiter, Lull. Puppe spielt doch eh keiner.
Und dann haben sie irgendwann festgestellt, nach ein paar Monaten,
WTF, warum spielen das die Leute?
Ja, dann, lass mal mit zweit im Team Fortnite umbauen zu einem Battle Royale Spiel.
Und wir haben Leute, die wissen, wie man Games macht.
Und zack, Puppe weggefickt.
Ey, musst du das ja nochmal vergleichen?
Du merkst einfach, du musst dir beide Spiele nur mal angucken.
Da siehst du schon, wer das Spiel entwickelt hat, der weiß, wie es geht.
Und wer das Spiel entwickelt hat, der eigentlich keine Ahnung hat, wie es geht.
Was ist denn los?
Warum movet sich der Wissert nicht?
Und das siehst du sofort.
Fortnite hat einfach irgendwie, wie soll man es nennen, so Charakter.
Fortnite hat einen Wiedererkennungswert, Fortnite hat irgendwie Charakter.
Sowohl vom Charakterdesigner, als auch vom Charakterbilder.
Fortnite hat irgendwie Charakter, sowohl vom Charakterdesigner, als auch von der Grafik.
Du kannst es über Comic-Geschichte streiten.
Es läuft gut, was Puppe bis heute nicht macht.
Es hat einen gewissen Wiedererkennungswert.
Es hat Emotes und solche Dinger.
Du merkst einfach, dass die wissen, wie man Games macht.
Die Steuerung fühlt sich gut an, dagegen sieht Puppe aus, wie aus dem Unity Baukasten.
Auch wenn es nicht Unity ist.
Und man merkt einfach, dass Unreal 4 nicht unbedingt gedacht ist, wenn man nicht gerade Epic Games ist,
nicht unbedingt gedacht ist, dafür Open-World-Spiele zu machen.
Also quasi Open-World, wo permanent alles geladen ist und passieren kann.
Dass Epic Games das hinkriegt mit Unreal 4, wundert mich nicht.
Die machen das, das kommt ja von denen, die können es ja anpassen, wie sie wollen.
Was Bluehole wahrscheinlich nicht kann.
Entweder sowohl fähig- keitentechnisch als auch Engine-Intern-Technisch können sie das nicht.
Na, Fortnite hat mit Sicherheit Probleme.
Aber es läuft, wie gesagt, ich habe ja beide Games nicht lang gespielt.
Fortnite gar nicht, wirklich, eigentlich PUBG auch nicht.
Und das läuft, kannste nichts sagen.
Und das muss wohl auch wirklich auf ziemlich den Kruppel rechnen, also ziemlich alten Kisten wunderbar funktionieren.
Ja, Beat-Pro und das finde ich auch.
Also bei der Kohle, die die scheffeln, mit PUBG hätte ich auch erwartet, dass die da mal Leute dransetzen,
die wissen, was sie machen, das Problem ist, könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass selbst, wenn du das, also du kannst halt nicht von heute auf morgen alles austauschen.
Wenn es erstmal verkackt ist, dann ist es halt verkackt.
Und du kannst sowas wie PUBG nicht einfach mal aus dem Ärmel schütteln und grundlegend erneuern.
Was nämlich heißen würde, wenn du das grundlegend erneuerst, heißt es, du entwickelst ein halbes Jahr an einem Game rum.
Und wenn du fertig bist, hast du quasi das gleiche Game ein halbes Jahr lang.
Und du hast ein halbes Jahr lang das gleiche Game, weil du in der Zeit das halt neu bastelst, wo sich nichts großartig tut.
Und nach dem halben Jahr hast du dann das alte Game eben neu mit dem gleichen Inhalt.
Du weißt, du hast quasi mal einfach fast ein Jahr oder so die Spieler nicht mit ordentlich Content versorgen können,
weil du hast halt das Game in neu und alles super und es läuft gut.
Aber wahrscheinlich sind in der Zwischenzeit die Spieler schon weggerannt, weil sich ein Dreiviertel Jahr oder Jahr in dem Spiel nichts getan hat.
Also einfach mal aus dem Ärmel schütteln neu ist, ist schwierig.
Und ich meine klar, die könnten einfach Leute drauf schmeißen.
Wir könnten das machen wie Epic Games mit Fortnite quasi im stillen Kämmerlein ein neues Pub gebasteln, was besser läuft und dann raushaut.
Ach was weiß ich, was die da machen.
Ich denke mir auch bei der Kohle, diese Scheffeln sollte das ordentlich laufen.
Das denke ich mir übrigens bei BDO auch.
BDO ist auch so ein schönes Beispiel für, wo ich nicht verstehen kann, wie man das da so servertechnisch verkacken kann.
Es ist immer schwierig einzuschätzen, wenn man die Architektur von dem Spiel nicht kennt oder generell von der Anwendung nicht kennt,
nicht genau weiß, wie das entstanden ist und alles mögliche.
Ich glaube, ich muss jetzt, wir machen jetzt die eine Rotation noch und dann gehe ich hoch, halte Nova Cell.
Ich bin schon fast wieder überladen. Also es ist immer schwierig einzuschätzen.
Aber BDO ist auch das beste Beispiel für.
Die müssen mit BDO ordentlich Kohle machen.
Die müssen wirklich ordentlich Kohle machen.
Das Team von Pearl Abyss muss relativ klein sein, wie gesagt.
Nur Hörensagen von irgendwelchen Berichten und Sachen, die man so liest.
Dementsprechend tun sie sich halt auch schwer mit neuen Sachen und halt auch die Technik von BDO drunter.
Merkste, dass das an vielen Stellen mit sehr, sehr heißer Nadel gestrickt ist, BDO.
Aber also BDO fühlt sich an vielen Stellen an wie so ein einziger Hotfix oder wie ein einziger Walkaround an manchen Stellen.
Auch wenn man sieht, wie das Sachen, ihr müsst mal, guckt mal.
Seht ihr hier hinten, guckt euch mal da hinten die Büsche an.
Guckt mal die Büsche an und jetzt laufe ich mal auf die Büsche zu.
Also ich laufe jetzt schnell, ich teleportiere mich jetzt auf die Büsche zu.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Seht ihr, wie das reingehört?
Da fällt mir irgendein Dreck, ja.
Solche Sachen hat BDO halt zuhauf.
Aber die Schäfeln mit dem Geld und auch Kakao Schäfeln mit dem Geld bestimmt einen riesen Haufen Kohle.
Wenn man sich anguckt, wie schön, also schön in Anführungsstrichen, die ganze Microtransaction und Shop-Geschichte in das Game integriert ist,
sodass du quasi nie das Gefühl hast, du musst jetzt unbedingt kaufen, aber du immer so den Anreiz im Nacken hast,
so irgendwie, ja ich kauf mir jetzt doch was und da noch ein bisschen Crafting-Zeugs und so.
Die müssen massig Kohle mit dem Game schäfeln.
Und da kann ich verstehen, wie man es nicht auf die Reihe kriegen kann seit Monaten.
Und wie gesagt, ich spiele ja noch nicht mal großartig aktiv.
Ich bin ja AFK-Noob, ich stehe ja immer nur rum und mache Daily-Rewards und ab und zu mal Nodes erneuern und das auch nicht mal.
Ich mache ja eigentlich nichts.
Aber es ist quasi seit ich das spiele, sind die Server so beschissen,
das habe ich so in dem Umfang selten in einem anderen MMO gesehen, höchstens nur an Patch-Tagen oder an Addon-Releases oder sowas.
Also das ist hier teilweise grausam.
Und vielleicht habt ihr das ja gestern mitverfolgt.
Sie haben es wohl letzte Woche geschafft, aber vielleicht weiß da einer von euch genauer,
Sie haben es ja letzte Woche geschafft, mit sechs oder sieben Gilden den Server zu crashen, weil die alle zusammen zum Node War gegangen sind.
Und gestern auf den EU-Servern haben sie es ja auch wieder geschafft, den Server zu crashen.
Da sind aber irgendwie 27 Gilden oder so zum Node War gegangen.
Die wollten quasi damit ein Zeichen setzen, so nach dem Motto, guckt mal, eure Server funktionieren nicht richtig.
Und das verstehe ich nicht, wenn man so viel Kohle mit dem Game scheffelt,
dass man da nicht einfach mal einen ordentlichen Server hinstellen kann.
Guckt euch mal das da hinten an, ey.
Evoli, das hat nichts mit dem Server zu tun, die Tor Distance.
Aber die gleichen Typen, die den kleinen programmiert haben, haben mit Sicherheit auch die Server software programmiert.
Guckt euch das da hinten mal an, ey.
Mit so heißer Nadel wie das hier gestrickt, das ist garantiert die Server-Seite von BDO auch gestrickt.
Aber das verstehe ich nicht, dass man das mit so viel Kohle nicht auf die Reihe kriegt,
weil, wie gesagt, das ist bestimmt auch mit sehr heißer Nadel gestrickt die BDO-Server-Geschichte
und wird nicht sonderlich gut optimiert sein und wahrscheinlich auch sehr eklig und keiner wird mal richtig durchblicken.
Aber meistens kann man auf Server Hardware, also bei Performance-Problemen bei Servern kannst du oftmals einfach Hardware draufschmeißen.
Und es wird ja wohl auch nicht so sein, dass quasi die Server, die man hier in der Server-Übersicht sieht,
das entspricht ja mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit, auch wenn ich die Architektur und so von BDO nicht kenne,
entspricht mit sehr, also diese Server-Dings hier, wo ist es denn?
Moment, hä? Wo stand denn das jetzt noch mal? Hier Server-Change.
Genau, also diese Server-Liste hier, die man hier sieht, die entspricht sehr, sehr sicher nicht 1 zu 1 einem Server.
Und es wird nicht so sein, dass Karma Sylvia 1 eine Hardware-Kiste ist, die im Rechenzentrum steht.
What the fuck, mein Drucker druckt.
Ich habe mich jetzt übelst erschreckt gerade, ey Leute. Alter, Woodface.
Mein Drucker hat einfach angefangen zu drucken.
Sachen, Alter, das gibt es nicht. MonkaS, Herzinfarkt.
Das ist von meinem zweiten Rechner Sachen, die ich mal vor einem halben Jahr auf Ausdrucken gedrückt habe, ey.
So, jetzt habe ich, Leute, wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben?
Wo bin ich, wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben?
Sagt es mir mal kurz. Ich habe es jetzt voll, voll entfernt verloren.
BDO Server, genau. So, und das, was man hier, jetzt habe ich auch den richtigen Knopf gefunden.
Das, was man hier sieht, ist mit Sicherheit nicht 1 zu 1 ein Server.
Also sprich, es wird nicht so sein, dass hier für Karma Sylvia, dass quasi bei denen im Rechenzentrum ein Server steht,
eine Hardware-Kiste steht, wo Karma Sylvia 1 dran steht, und da wird auch keine Hardware-Kiste stehen, wo Valencia 2 dran steht.
Es wird sehr wahrscheinlich so sein, dass auch nicht das hier quasi, ne, also wisst ihr, ich bin jetzt hier auf einem Channel
und die ganze, ganze Worldmap dann irgendwie auf diesen Server laufen wird, es wird wahrscheinlich viel eher so sein,
dass uns unterschiedliche Server für unterschiedliche Regionen geben wird
und auch noch nicht mal, noch nicht mal in der heutigen Zeit eine Hardware-Kiste,
die fest jetzt für, keine Ahnung, hier unten sind wenig Leute, irgendwie da so zuständig ist,
sondern das Ganze wird wahrscheinlich, hoffe ich mal, für die relativ dynamisch sein.
Also wenn hier jetzt viele Leute sind, können sich da auch mal ein bisschen mehr Hardware drum kümmern als da drum oder hier oben,
hier oben, das braucht wahrscheinlich überhaupt nichts, weil da ist keine Sau.
Also das wird schon alles ein bisschen dynamischer gehandhabt sein, ein bisschen dynamischer geregelt sein
und deswegen kann man wahrscheinlich bei Performance-Problemen bis zu einem gewissen Grad einfach Hardware draufschmeißen.
Du schmeißt einfach stärkere Hardware drauf, du kaufst einfach, einfach dickes Zeug rein.
Weiß ja nicht, auf was das aktuell so läuft, ich will mein Zeug zählen.
Na, was, wenn du schon sagst, dass die Server beschissen laufen, dann wäre ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Ich kann es mir nicht anders vorstellen.
Bei so einer dynamischen, letztendlich bei so einer dynamischen Welt, was da passiert
und wie bevölkert die Welt überall ist, wäre es bescheuert.
Das kannst du, kannst du klicken.
Das muss aufgesplittet sein.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Ja, das können wir ins Marketplace, die ganzen anderen Krempel können wir verkaufen.
Jetzt verkaufen wir erstmal die ganzen Country Talks, das brauchen wir nicht.
Zack, zack.
Jetzt haben wir ansonsten nur das Zeug, das kann man in die Truhe legen.
Das nimmt nicht viel weg.
Zack, zack, zack, zack.
Hab ich jetzt gerade irgendwas gesellt, was ich nicht zählen wollte?
Komm, scheiß drauf, wir zählen das auch.
Jetzt haben wir wieder genug Platz.
Kaufen wir nochmal eine Runde Potions.
Gab es denn nochmal Potions da?
Bewerb dich dort für einen Monatspraktiker.
Ganz bestimmt.
Die GM Max gibt es dann.
Wobei die GMs ja mit der ganzen Sache absolut gar nichts zu tun haben.
Die müssen den Kram bloß ausbaden.
GMs sind im Endeffekt das, was der Zugbegleiter bei der Bahn ist.
Der kann nichts dafür, dass es Verspätung gibt, aber der muss es den Leuten erzählen und es denen verkaufen.
Sowas wie der Pressesprecher quasi.
Der erfährt die Sachen, die passiert sind zuletzt und muss den Krams trotzdem verkaufen.
Nee, es war das Falsche. Ich kann mir mein Buff-Food nie merken.
Ich wollte irgendwann mal auch so ein Buff-Timer-Food-Programm basteln.
Hab ich aber nie gemacht.
Ich denke, die könnten da einfach noch ein bisschen fettere Hardware draufhauen.
Wie gesagt, es ist immer saumäßig schwierig, dazu was zu sagen.
Reicht noch. Nochmal für 500 Katres reicht es.
Danach müssen wir nämlich eh hier in die Wüste.
Oh, wie es ruckelt.
Dafür müssen wir eh in die Wüste nachher hoch.
Und Kram verkaufen.
Also wie gesagt, ich glaube, da könnten sie einfach ein bisschen Hardware draufschmeißen.
Natürlich kostet Hardware Geld.
Hardware Geld ist eigentlich immer relativ überschaubar.
Wenn du Hardware kaufst, dann weißt du, was auf dem Zettel steht.
Du weißt, was es kostet. Du weißt, was du ausgegeben hast.
Das ist nicht so, dass du das Ding einbaust und dann feststellst, oh fuck,
es kostet jetzt ja doch noch was Doppelte oder so.
Das kaufst du halt und baust ein und dann ist gut.
Aber es ist schwierig zu sagen.
Man weiß halt nicht, wie es im Hintergrund funktioniert.
Aber zumindest kann ich aus eigener Erfahrung sagen,
in der Regel, wenn du Performanceprobleme auf Server hast,
das Beste ist, also den meisten Gewinn oder die meisten Performanceverbesserungen
kannst du in der Regel nicht mit neuer Hardware,
sondern mit verbessertem Software rausholen.
Weil wenn irgendwie was nicht sonderlich durchdacht programmiert ist,
und es langsam ist, dann ist es auf dem neuen Server ja auch immer noch langsam,
aber es läuft halt ein bisschen schneller, weil die Hardware schneller ist.
Aber was man immer gut machen kann, ist erstmal ordentlich Hardware draufschmeißen
und gucken, ob es das nicht irgendwie erträglicher macht für alle.
Und sich dann überlegen, ok, was kann man ändern.
Es gibt auch Sachen, die brauchen halt einfach Rechenleistung.
Du kannst nicht alles optimieren, bis es in einem CPU-Takt durch ist.
Das funktioniert nicht, ja.
Also wenn Leute immer schreiben, ja, da muss man das, das und das hier besser optimieren
und hier besser optimieren, irgendwann hat es auch mal die Grenze erreicht,
wo man was optimieren kann.
Geht auch nicht unendlich weit.
Beziehungsweise dort erreicht, wo es irgendwie noch realistisch ist.
Es hat ja auch keinen Sinn, seine Codebase, sein Sourcecode,
sagen wir mal, auf 50% aufzuplänen, um es 3% schneller an manchen Stellen zu machen,
wenn es jetzt nicht irgendwie super kritisch ist.
Da hast du nämlich ganz andere Probleme.
Aber so viel dazu.
Und es ist ja nicht so, dass das Spiel, das BDO nicht lauffähig wird.
BDO läuft ja meistens ganz gut.
Bis halt zu dem Punkt, wo diese Grenze überschritten ist, wo es dann halt kacke läuft.
Und diesen Punkt könnte man halt mit neuer Hardware, denke ich,
noch ein bisschen weiter verschieben, sodass das viel seltener vorkommen würde.
Aber letztendlich müssen wir uns darauf verlassen,
dass die da einen besseren Einblick drauf haben oder drinnen haben.
Die haben sie definitiv als wir.
Und dass sie das Beste machen.
Allerdings nicht das Beste für uns als Spieler, sondern das Beste für sich.
Und das Beste für die ist mit Sicherheit nicht immer das Beste für uns.
Ja, mein Pet ist hier permanent am Neusporn, weil es das kann.
Warum es das macht, weil es sich ordnet.
Macht es gern.
Das ist mein Pet, irgendeiner Lappen. Ja, das ist mein Pet.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum das immer, immer Neusporn.
Ich weiß nicht, weil es nicht schnell genug hinterherrennen kann.
Und jetzt meint, es müsste jetzt bei mir spawnen.
Sie hätten dem Pet auch einfach einen Speedbuff geben können.
Anstatt dass das Pet bei mir neu spawnen,
hätte es einfach mal auch kurz einen Speedbuff kriegen können, wo es zu mir vorrennt.
Aber da sind wir wieder beim Thema.
In BDO ist vieles mit heißer Nadel gestrickt.
Und das sieht man wieder an solchen Dingern.
Das war wahrscheinlich einfach einfacher, das Pet kurz despawnen zu lassen, neu aufzukloppen,
anstatt dem Pet kurz einen Speedbuff zu geben oder sowas.
Und einen Speedbuff könntest du wahrscheinlich auch im PvP irgendwie missbrauchen.
Und das hat dann 100.000 Auswirkungen wieder.
Deswegen besser spawnen.
Und du hast Leute... Moment, hier ist alles down.
Und du hast Leute gespart, die Laufanimationen machen müssen für das Pet.
Die Laufanimationen für das Pet.
Das ist ja immer voller hier.
Ist Catree überhaupt Worst? Keine Ahnung ab wann sich das lohnt.
Aber ich mach das gar nicht, weil es das großartig Worst ist.
Sondern ich mach das für Quests.
Ich mach das für...
Wat?
Moment.
Kack Boss.
Ich mach das für Schmuck Upgrade Quests.
Also ich muss 4 Marni Stones abgeben.
Für die hier...
Unstoppable Thrust for Power 3.
So, dann haben wir es ja gleich, wir haben es gleich.
Noch 200 Stück, easy. 200 Stück.
Danach gehen wir Desert Nagas bashen.
Übrigens, wer Wizard bei mir im Stream sieht denkt Wizard hat nur 3 Spells.
Wizard hat eigentlich übelst viele Spells.
Und auch relativ gute Spells, auch aus der alten Linie noch.
Man hat ja mittlerweile sogar diese Spell Upgrades.
Das hab ich überhaupt nicht gespeckt.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile noch 2 absolut OP Spells für einen Wizard.
Die hab ich noch gar nicht.
Zwar die hier.
Wo an das hier unten die?
Irgendwie einen Instant Heal.
Genau, Instant A.E. Heal kriegste.
Genau, Instant A.E. Heal kriegste noch.
Und voll irgendwie den übertriebenen A.E. alles weg Nuked Zauber.
Hab ich auch noch gar nicht geskillt.
Ich bin auch nicht so up to date, was hier in den letzten Patches gekommen ist.
Zumindest haben wir diese Country Quest.
Danach fehlen uns bloß noch Desert Nagas und Desert Fogans.
Und dann haben wir den Gürtel auf Ted.
Und dann kommt noch eine Quest.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das auch wieder so ein Crying Fest ist, wie das hier.
Was? Du kannst eine davon wählen und danach wieder ein aus zwei?
Versteh ich nicht.
Ich kann nicht beides skilln. Warum hab ich dann zwei Skill Slots?
Ach so. Ach so. Ach so. Man kann hier einmal zwischen auswählen und hier einmal zwischen auswählen.
Ach so.
Okay, es gibt einen Instant A.E. Heal.
Ich hab mir das noch nie angeguckt.
Es gibt einen Instant A.E. Heal oder einen A.E. Nuke.
Und als nächstes gibt es einen A.E. Kram und nochmal A.E. Damage.
Das muss ich mir nachher mal angucken.
Was ist da die OP Kombination?
Der Heal vom ersten und der A.E. Damage vom zweiten oder zweimal A.E. Damage?
Was ist da mehr OP?
Was lässt meinen Wizard noch mehr Damage machen, als er eh schon macht?
Vom ersten lohnt sich der Heal. Gleich, gleich. Du schaust ja alles.
Der Heal Weste.
Okay.
Könnte ich eigentlich mal skilln jetzt?
Hab ich denn genug Punkte überhaupt?
Ich glaube, ich hab gar nicht genug Punkte. Guck mal.
Man kann das doch auch Respecken, oder?
Leute, man kann das bestimmt Respecken. Man kann in dem Game alles Respecken.
Desweifels fallen mir Pearl-Shop-Items Respecken.
Da ist da schon wieder einer.
Komm, ich brauch noch 80 Katris. Kostet keine Punkte.
Dann skilln wir das. Das skilln wir gleich mal.
Ich mach jetzt noch meine 50 Katris, meine 70 Katris kaputt.
Und dann skilln wir mal den Heal.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Zumal ich benutze ja eh meine ganzen Skills nicht, ne?
Ich hab mir meinen Instant-Cast extra auf X gelegt, dass ich den öfters mache.
Und ich mach ihn jetzt gar nicht.
So bin ich halt.
So übelst faul, wenn so was geht.
Zumal man als Wizard auch von den alten Spells noch richtig gute hat, ne?
So zum Beispiel hier. So zum Beispiel dieses Gegner einfrieren.
Das riecht gut. Das geht auch auf PvP-Gegner.
Frag mich nicht, warum ich das nicht öfters verwende.
Ich hab's mir sogar extra schon auf der Taste gelegt, weil ich es öfters verwenden will.
Aber aus irgendwelchen unerfindlichen Gründen mach ich das nicht.
Genau, warum auch mehr benutzen als nötig.
Das sehe ich auch so. Easy Wizard-Crime. Mein Lava-Feld könnte ich auch mal öfters verwenden.
Aber es reicht ja im Prinzip als Wizard rein daschen, Feuer-AE, Wasser-AE.
Bam, alles tot. Next.
Oder manchmal reicht es auch rein daschen, Wasser-AE. Fertig.
Also als Wizard musst du zumindest mit PvM gar nichts können.
Aber wenn ich jetzt den neuen PvM-Gürtel am Start hab mit plus 15 AP, dann ist das noch einfacher.
Ich muss mich dann auch mal ein bisschen damit beschäftigen bzw. den Fabian befragen,
was für Kristalle und so, für Waffen und Handschuhe und sowas.
Und bei Handschuhe weiß ich so halbwegs schon, was man am besten macht.
Ach so, ich bin schon fertig.
Gut, fertig. Das heißt, äh, Speed, Speed, Speed.
Was brenne ich denn hin?
Rennen wir mal nach Dings Bazaar hoch. Sand-Kra-Bazaar.
Selber das Zeug retten und gehen deshalb nach Gas-Kloppen.
Komm, wie rennt der Wizard? Ich brauch überhaupt kein Pferd.
Da geht übelst ab. Guckt euch das mal an.
Zwischendurch kannst du noch mal porten, eine Runde, dann rennst du weiter.
Der flitzt. Der flitzt richtig, der Wizard.
Der hat auch kaum Endu verbraucht, ne?
Der flitzt da wieder.
Weil im Spiel gefällt... Moment.
Die Spielwelt ist auch eines der großen Stärken von dem Game.
BDO ist das erste MMO, wo ich gesehen habe, dass sie es schaffen,
die komplette Spielwelt halbwegs bevölker zu halten.
Übrigens, hier unten ist noch nichts, ne?
Also hier kommt in Zukunft mit irgendwelchen Add-ons noch was hin.
Die Welt geht im Endeffekt von hier so bis hier.
Hier kommt irgendwann mal so ein Schneegebiet noch bis...
Wizard, laufen.
Bis hier hinter geht die Spielwelt.
Aber es ist trotzdem saumäßig groß.
Also die Spielwelt ist riesig, zumal es ja noch hier oben weitergeht.
Also du hast hier noch Inseln, du hast hier noch jede Menge Inseln.
Und du hast, wenn man drauf steht, ewig übers Meer zu düsen mit einem Schiff.
Kann man, glaube ich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man hier irgendwo noch hin kann.
Aber zumindest kann man bis hier hochfahren.
Hier ist dann auch Schluss.
Also die Spielwelt ist wirklich groß.
Und sie haben es geschafft, dass die Spielwelt immer überall halbwegs bevölkert ist.
Ich meine mal, hier oben jetzt mal außen vor.
Hier oben im Meer, da ist eigentlich nichts.
Es sind kaum Leute.
Aber vor allem hier in den alten Gebieten, also quasi wo das Spiel auch released wurde,
war das, glaube ich, ging es hier irgendwie nur so bis hier, oder?
Irgendwie sowas.
Ich muss mal vor allem fragen, da war das bestimmt besser.
Nee, ich glaube, bis hier ging das sogar nur.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, das hier war so irgendwie...
Das hier unten war irgendwie so groß bei der Welt, als es rausgekommen ist.
Und trotzdem, obwohl es quasi so das alte Low-Level-Gebiet ist hier unten,
ist hier immer noch massig los.
Vor allem auch durch das Crafting- und Life-Skill- und sonst was-System
lohnt es sich immer irgendwo, irgendwo was zu machen.
Und man macht ja hier auch Progress nicht unbedingt nur pro Held,
sondern also quasi pro, wie ich glaube, Familie nennen sie das, also quasi für alle Helden.
Also jeder Held hat...
Wenn du jetzt hier irgendwie was aufgedeckt hast oder irgendwo gewesen,
hat das jeder Held.
Das musst du nicht neu machen für jeden Held, also für jeden Charakter.
Ich habe eben was zur Training gelesen mit dem Karen von A nach B fahren.
Hast du dazu Infos?
Ja, also ich habe das mit dem Karren rumfahren, habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Das Spiel hat aber mehrere, wie nennt man das, mehrere Wirtschaftsstrenge,
wo man was machen kann.
Du kannst natürlich Training machen, du kannst hier irgendwie...
Du kannst hier unten im Wald irgendwelche Holzkisten basteln
und die dann in die Wüste tragen und dann übelst viel Kohle für kassieren,
also so wirklich händlermäßig.
Du kannst eben mit dem Karren rumfahren und du kannst halt hier diese ganzen Nodes,
die es hier gibt.
Also auf der Map sind ja immer so Nodes.
Mitten jeweils im Node Manager, das muss man halt mit dem NPC reden,
da steht dann da rum.
Und an vielen Nodes kann man auch Arbeit dahinschicken, die dann halt was abbauen für einen.
Zum Beispiel hier gibt es dann Zink und Kohle und sowas kann man abbauen.
Und man kann dort nur abbauen, wenn man sie quasi mit einem starken Node verbunden hatten, sowas.
Das ist übelst komplex, das System.
Und ist für viele quasi so eine Wissenschaft für sich, hier das Optimale rauszuholen
aus Worker und Nodes.
Weil du hast die ganze Liste an Workern, die haben dann auch verschieden Level,
verschiedene Skills und frag mich nicht, das ist übelst kompliziert.
Und zumindest für alle, die dann auch mal ganz gerne mit ihrem Held was machen,
hast du hier noch zig Skill-Varianten, was du sonst noch machen kannst.
Also man muss in dem Game nicht unbedingt was machen, man kann auch die ganze Zeit rumstehen
und craften, wenn man dann drauf irgendwie scharf ist.
Ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Ja, ich sollte mal ein Worker ein Bier geben, das stimmt,
ich habe gar kein Bier dabei.
Da muss ich jetzt auf den Berser umlocken.
Ich spiele das eh nur AFK, das Game.
Also AFK, das stimmt noch nicht mal, ich spiele das Game nicht AFK.
Ich spiele das Game eigentlich nur per Daily Rewards.
Also meistens, ne, 90% der Zeit mache ich den BDO,
logge ich einmal am Tag ein, hole Daily Rewards und logge wieder aus.
Und ab und zu spiele ich dann mal ein bisschen.
Aber man hat es gesehen, easy Tab-Thunder.
Soll ich einfach nur regelmäßig einloggen und Rewards abgreifen.
Und nächsten Monat gibt es Duo-Ogering.
All nächstes, nächsten Monat habe ich 100 Charcato Seals zusammen.
Dann kann ich mir einen Duo-Ogre holen.
So jetzt müssen wir erstmal rappen.
Wo war denn der reparier-Typ? Der war doch hier auch irgendwo.
Habe ich 100 Chacartos Seals zusammen, kann ich mir einen
Duogre
holen
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal rappen
Nee, wo war denn der Repariertyp, der war doch hier auch irgendwo
Hä?
War der
Moment, ist das der Repariertyp?
Der Furniture Dealer repariert auch
Okay, ja, klingt ja auch logisch
Ja, so als Schreiner
Also da reparier ich auch immer Schwerter und magische Waffen
Das ist easy, kein Ding
Wer kennt das nicht?
Ich hab so irgendwas sonst was zum Verkaufen
So, hab ich sonst irgendwas zum Sellen
Ja, genau
Nicht wirklich
Wie viel Platz hab ich hier noch im Vault?
Ja, es macht sich Platz, geh schon mal kurz zum Vault hoch
So, ich lauf mal zum Vault hoch und ich geh mal kurz aufs Klo
Fortnite Stream? Ja, ganz bestimmt
Was, der Storage ist jetzt auch da?
Was? War der nicht immer auf dem Berg oben?
Ich bin überhaupt nicht mehr up to date hier, ich weiß gar noch Bescheid
Ah nee, die verkaufen wir erst noch mal
Gibt's Exp?
Mehr Exp
So, und jetzt brauchen wir noch Desert Nagas da unten
3, 4
Hab ich mich jetzt verzählt?
Ja, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4
4, 1, 2, 3, 4
1, 2, 3, 4
Ja, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4
Ok, dann pack ich noch mal ein bisschen Zeug in den Vault
Und dann muss ich unbedingt mal aufs Klo
Das Zeug brauch ich jetzt eh nicht mehr
Was wiegt denn hier viel? Die Heiltränke wiegen massig, ne?
Ah, wir haben noch Katri Zeug übrig
So, jetzt gehen wir Desert Naga Bash machen
Items haben wir geredeppt
Oh, mal kurz aufs Klo
Ich mach euch mal die passende
Passende
Musik an
Ich mach jetzt mal den
Der letzte
Der Soundtrack aus der letzten Dragon Ball Folge
Den fand ich übertrieben nice
Wo ist er denn?
So, kurz auf
Musik
Kokona
So, Desert Naga Bash
Ja, die letzte Folge fand ich auch übertrieben geil
Ich hab ja nie geguckt sonst
Musik
So
Den Crying Spot kennen wir ja noch
Da hab ich ja Level 60 gemacht vor ein paar Monaten
Musik
Wo war denn hier ein gescheiter Spot?
Stimmt, da muss man hier runter
Musik
Hast du schon mal Leaf angeschaut?
Ne
Ich muss auch sagen
Weltraumzeug
Also Weltraum immer im Osten ist es
Irgendwie reiz mich das gar nicht
Musik
Dementsprechend lässt mich auch Star Citizen
übelst kalt
Also Star Citizen lässt mich total kalt
Ich hab den Hype um Star Citizen noch nie richtig
nie verstanden
Musik
Vielleicht kann mir den jemand erklären
So
Ok, weiter gehts
Das dauert ewig die Quest
500 Nagas
500 Fogens
So siehts aus
Musik
Und mit den ganzen anderen Typen hier am Start
wird das nichts
Musik
Fogens einfach
Wenigstens fallen die Nagas jetzt schön um
seitdem ich jetzt hier ordentlich APs hab
Bam
Wisst ihr noch wie wir uns dann abgebrochen haben auf Level 60?
Hast du jedes Pack 3 Spells
gebraucht?
Jetzt wird da einfach einmal reingedashed
Bam
Alles kaputt
So muss das sein
Musik
Einmal AE rein
Down
So gehört sich das
Musik
So irgendwie krieg ich langsam Hunger
Social eating incoming
Musik
Da unten ist noch was
Ja also ich denke die Quest waren wir heute auf jeden Fall fertig
Musik
Auch wenn es noch ein bisschen dauert
Wie gesagt wir müssen jetzt hier
4 Kristalle Nagas voll machen
Danach 4 Kristalle Fogens voll machen
Dann fertig
Sushis, Sushi das ist eigentlich
Nussmüller das ist eigentlich
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee
Sushi stream
Also nicht Sushi stream sondern Sushi bestellen
Das wäre eigentlich
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee
Musik
Eigentlich könnte ich mir eine Runde Sushi bestellen
Da hätte ich übrigens Bock wieder drauf
Sushor
Musik
Sushi Chef
Die haben aber bestimmt heute nicht auf
Feiertag
Musik
Eigentlich haben die nicht auf
Ich muss da mal gucken
Jetzt wieder eine Runde Sushi
Musik
Also BDO
Ermüdet nach einer Weile schon ein bisschen
Vor allem wenn man halt so eine wahnsinnig
Spannende Quest machen muss
Das ist ja
Ist schon eines muss ich ja sagen
Ist schon eines der spannendsten MMO
Quests aller Zeiten hier
Musik
Da ist alles andere nichts dagegen
Wie finanziert sich das Spiel
Abo Modell oder
Bye To Play
Das ist eine Kombination
Aus
Bye To Play
Und In Game Store
Musik
die dir das Leben leichter machen, wo du schneller bist, was natürlich auch wieder letztendlich unterm Strich dazu führt, dass du Gegner einfacher blatt machen kannst, ja?
Wenn du in der gleichen Zeit
mehr schaffst als ein anderer Spieler, wirst du irgendwann besseres,
besser ausgerüstet sein als er in der gleichen Zeit
und du ihn blatt machen, aber das ist nicht so extrem, ich meine es basiert sehr viel auf Glück in dem Game,
also sprich,
du kannst auch übeles Glück haben, kannst aber auch, obwohl du Geld ausgegeben hast,
voll in die Tonne greifen.
Warum ist denn hier so voll?
Hier ist zu voll.
Also jeder der BDO ernsthaft, wieviele Leute sind hier denn?
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, jeder der BDO angefangen hat und dann gesagt hat, er will das ein bisschen
ausführlicher spielen, ja, ein bisschen öfter spielen und länger spielen, der wird auch Kohle ausgegeben haben.
Gehe ich mal von aus, so was, so was wie, sagen wir mal, so was wie ein Pet, ist ja nix mehr, das ist kacke,
alles kaputt, ich muss doch mal einen Channel wechseln, also so was wie Pet, das ist ja nix mehr,
also so was, so was wie ein Pet, das ist ja nix mehr, das ist ja nix mehr, das ist ja nix mehr, das ist ja nix mehr,
das ist kacke, alles kaputt, ich muss doch mal einen Channel wechseln, also so was wie Pets zum Beispiel,
ist was, das kriegt man zwar auch manchmal aus Daily Rewards,
beziehungsweise kriegt man, kriegt man manchmal irgendwie noch aus dem Marketplace gesnipet oder so, wenn man viel Glück hat,
aber in der Regel sind die meisten Leute, die haben sich die Pets aus dem Shop geholt
und Pets sind halt was, das ist schon sehr praktisch.
Also nicht das, was da gerade hinter mir herrennt, alles, aber wenn man sich guckt, was Pets machen, also Pets heben,
einmal eben heben halt Loot auf, ohne das hält man es eigentlich gar nicht aus, stellt euch mal vor,
ihr müsst zu jedem, stellt euch mal vor, ich müsste zu jedem Gegner gehen und einmal R drücken für Loot,
da wirst du doch verrückt,
das funktioniert, also das funktioniert schon, aber das macht keiner, der noch irgendwie bei Verstand ist.
Moin Anton Prank,
also Pets sind so ne Sache, das lohnt sich, eigentlich für jeden, der anfängt damit.
Es gibt nen Starter Kit, da sind glaub ich ein paar Pets drinnen,
sind die wie ein Hund oder Katze, gibt's glaub ich in irgendeinem Starter Pack,
die Starter Packs sind eh nicht schlecht, da kriegt man, da kriegt man Value Packs drinnen,
kriegt man Pets, ich glaub sogar ein Pferd, weiß nicht mehr, was in dem Starter Pack genau drin ist,
aber das war, war nicht schlecht, also Ingame wird man dafür deutlich mehr bezahlen im Ingame Shop,
und die meisten Items sind auch nützlich,
ne ich mach hier ganz bestimmt, ne ne ne ich mach hier keine Guild oder sowas,
ich bin selbst der übelste Noob in dem Game, ich bin in der gleichen Guild wie der Fabian, fertig,
ey wie krieg ich so viel Damage von denen, das letzte Mal nicht so viel Damage gekriegt,
ich mein es ist als Wizard nicht so schlimm, kannst dich selbst heilen,
boah es ist langweilig BDO Quest, das ist so ultra langweilig,
keine Merpse da, wahrscheinlich wegen Desert Buff, kann sein, aber der macht gar nichts,
du kriegst eigentlich gar nicht so viel Damage, ne kommt man also kaum, aber ja klar, wenn das ein paar Minuten läuft,
ja wahrscheinlich ist es wegen Desert Buff, hast recht, ja hast recht, wird wegen Desert Buff sein,
und besser gesagt, Desert Buff, aber das ist ja als Wizard nicht weiter wild, drückt einfach ab und zu mal Heal, easy win,
besser gesagt easy clap, einfach zu voll,
Mopstar Father, wir sind dran glauben jetzt,
ja jetzt haben wir irgendwie die Musik ein bisschen leise geworden, oder hört man da gar nichts mehr,
ja Eaxe da ist was dran, es ruckelt tatsächlich weniger,
also zumindest in BDO scheint es echt an Shadowplay zu liegen, das ruckelt,
in anderen Games ist mir das noch gar nicht aufgefallen,
was gibt es denn im Spiel für Klassen, da musst du mal auf der BDO Seite gucken,
gibt es schon ein paar, ich weiß gar nicht ob ich aus dem Kopf alle selbst zusammen kriege,
also lass mal überlegen, es gibt Wizard Witch so als Range DD Caster, wobei Wizard ist ja nicht wirklich Range,
es gibt Wizard Witch, es gibt Striker Mystique, es gibt Zork, es gibt Maver und Moosa, es gibt Krieger und Bersi, Ranger, Dark Knight,
gibt es noch, habe ich was vergessen, gibt es noch, ich habe bestimmt was vergessen, Valkyrie genau,
ich glaube das war es, ich glaube wir haben alles und du kannst eigentlich prinzipiell mit jeder Klasse alles machen,
es gibt relativ viele, Mystique ist gerade so das OP Teil,
hier sind eindeutig zu viele Leute, so eins haben wir, jetzt fehlen uns bloß noch 900 Nagas,
nur noch 900 Nagas, nur noch 900 Nagas, easy, easy Naga Bash, es macht so Spaß Naga Bash,
es macht so Spaß Naga Bash, beste, es ist ja nicht so, dass ich hier irgendwie schon gefühlt 30 Stunden gewesen bin für Level 60,
der Kreisel Cry ist wieder am Start, gezwungenermaßen, aber gleich gehen wir mal an einen Spot, wo wir nicht so oft gewesen sind,
wir müssen nämlich noch 1000 Fogans Bashen, gucken ob ich das noch finde, das ist hier unten irgendwo war das, da müssen wir dann hin,
Fogans, Fogans oder Fogans, was bevorzugt ihr da, ich bin ja für Fogans, ich hoffe die ernähren sich auch Omnivore,
Omnivore Ernährung ist der Teufel, das haben wir letztens bei Ongen gelernt, ganz schlimm,
das ist zu dem Video von ihm noch nicht mal, dass das Wort Omnivore überhaupt existiert,
was macht man eigentlich mit diesen Eiern, das ist Oster Event, das habe ich kapiert,
was kriegt man dafür, steht nicht da, sieht man dann wahrscheinlich bei dem NPC,
BDO hat permanent irgendwelche Events laufen, die wollen ja, dass die Leute weiter am Start sind,
was kriegt man, was gibt es denn, weiß das jemand, was es für die EierQuest gibt,
nicht für die EierQuest, also nicht für die goldenen Eier, für diese Drop EierQuest,
gibt es da irgendwo so eine Tabelle, mit wieviel Eiern kriegt man soviel, muss ich mir
sagen, das lohnt, mehr Eier, ja das ist typische BDO Loot Taktik, eine Lootbox,
wenn man eine Lootbox rauskommt, um eine Lootbox rauszukriegen, wo dann ein Blackstone drin ist
oder so, das muss so sein, ja, hoffentlich haben die sich verdrückt hier, die komische
Eier eben, da habe ich genug, genug Karma, um die zu bashen, ja, gibt es noch
irgendwelche interessanten Themen in letzter Zeit, wo man drüber schwätzen könnte,
ich habe keine Idee, was ist in letzter Zeit so passiert online-mäßig, so könnte ich
mich noch hier jetzt mal auslassen, weil mir ist wirklich sehr langweilig, gerade wenn
ich so rumgekreide, das ist ultra langweilig, ich brauche irgendwas, worüber ich mich auslasse,
ich habe irgendwas, was ich erzählen kann, ist irgendwas interessantes passiert online-mäßig,
also da muss ich sowieso Philipp
Absolutely oben, ist mana die Rechnung, ist nur da oben.
nicht schon wieder
Aber es doch an sich ist doch gar kein problem breitbandausbau in deutschland wir haben doch bis ende
2018 alle 50 alle
komplett
Bis im letzten
Drei mann dorf im osten haben wir 50 mit das hat der pressesprecher letztes jahr gesagt ja der regierung
Und wenn er das sagt dann ist das so wo kommt diese ganze milch ist gift kram her
Ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt noch mal aufwärmen soll das kommt von youtube das kommt von youtube
Wo uns versucht ein
veganer youtuber seinen lebensstil quasi näher zu bringen
Ich glaube das habe ich das habe ich doch jetzt schön umschrieben oder
Ohne zu flähen
Wir sind überall leute. Wo bei ich habe gar keine so schlechte idee hier runter zu gehen
So wir haben fast wir haben fast nagellange Zeit
Ja der letzte pilger ausnahm bestätigen die regel soll vorkommen
Aber sie haben jetzt ja gesagt wir müssen schon an gigabit denken
Ich denke an gigabit schon seit den letzten zehn jahren ich weiß gar nicht ob wir jetzt an gigabit denken müssen
Ist ja nicht so das gigabit was neues wäre das ist so 2018 hoch auf einmal ist gigabit
da hat es vorher nicht abzusehen was jetzt ist es auf einmal da gigabit aber vorher vorher war das nicht da
Das ist sogar so outdated gigabit dass man mittlerweile daheim schon ohne probleme 10 gigabit
Netzwerk sich hinstellen kann für gar nicht mal so viel geld
Mein rechner ist per 10 gigabit angebunden mittlerweile und mein fileserver auch das heißt ich kann jetzt
mit 90 mb ziehen weil die festplatte nicht mehr hergibt aber ist per 10 gigabit angebunden
was muss das muss
wenn ich von der ssd ziehe kann ich wenigstens 500 mb ziehen
theoretisch 1,2 gigabyte ja richtig
brauchst aber halt erst mal was auf der anderen seite was so viel hinkriegt
habe ich noch nicht abgegeben auch gut dann geben wir das jetzt ab
das wird mich wahrscheinlich wach machen aber das macht mich dann wieder für den
ganzen tag fertig wenn ich jetzt overwatch spielen würde
manchmal denke ich immer so dran sollst du nicht mal eine runde spielen aber ich weiß
wie es die letzten mal ausgegangen ist jedes mal wenn ich wieder angefangen habe ein
bisschen auf erwacht zu spielen lief dann vielleicht auch wenn ich glück hatte lief
die ersten ein zwei runden dann so dass es Spaß gemacht hat habe ich mir immer
gedacht hey cool funktioniert läuft er wieder gut und dann dann kamen wieder die
richtigen sucker runden dann hat es hat es hat mich jedes mal richtig angepisst
deswegen dieses mal falle ich da nicht drauf rein ich spiele erst mal kein
overwatch mehr ich lasse mich nicht mehr weiter von overwatch wie es jetzt aus
hast du mal mit der overwatch gespielt in letzter zeit also außer die 33
placements oder sowas wo letztens geschrieben hast
alle nags oder so der opened
Ja, es ist genau so, dass das wegen
spiel ich auch kein Overwatch mehr, das nervt mich, das geht mir einfach nur ums Sack.
Ich glaube Overwatch,
das ist so blödsinn, so auch vom Namen her, ich glaube Overwatch wird immer mehr auch für alle Beteiligten zum
Zukunftsspiel, so zum Overwatch quasi, also es gibt es gibt sau viele Leute, die gucken,
die gucken Overwatch League, aber ich glaube ganz viele spielen gar nicht aktiv.
Ich glaube ganz viele machen das, so wie ich, die gucken Overwatch League, interessieren sich für Overwatch, finden auch, dass Overwatch ein gutes Spiel ist,
aber sind von dem Game selbst, beim Selbstspielen so abgefuckt, dass sie nicht spielen, aber sie gucken gerne.
Ich glaube das geht ganz vielen so.
Das wird dann wieder so zum reinen Guckspiel.
Wobei ich auch bei der ganzen Overwatch League, auch wenn die Zuschauer zahlen und so, das ist wirklich nicht schlecht,
hätte glaube ich keiner mit gerechnet,
dass sie da irgendwie von Anfang an 150k Zuschauer fahren, also quasi die Overwatch League hat so viele
Zuschauer wie Ninja bei Fortnite.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Und ich meine 150k ist verdammt viel auf Twitch, verdammt viel, muss ich mal vorstellen, ja,
quasi eine von Blizzard aufgezogene Liga, hat so viele Zuschauer wie ein Typ.
Das ist krass oder? Das ist übertrieben.
Also das hatte ich nie mit gerechnet, dass wir sowas mal sehen, aber so ist es halt bei Twitch.
Wenn man das alles auch vorausahnen könnte, wäre ja auch langweilig.
Aber was ich sagen wollte, ich habe allgemein so meine Zweifel, ob
sich die Overwatch League Geschichte,
auch wenn es gut aussieht mit den Zuschauern und so, ob sich das auf Dauer halten wird, weil es ist einfach so,
es gehört ja keinem so wirklich was da dran, es gehört ja alles Blizzard.
Also sprich,
nehmen wir jetzt mal Team Envyous oder Hastro als Team Envyous Owner hat sich,
es ist ja nicht so, dass Dallas Fuel quasi seine Marke oder sein Team wäre,
er durfte sich lediglich
bei Blizzard einkaufen. Dallas Fuel gehört Blizzard.
Also es gehört im Endeffekt keinem, der an der Overwatch League beteiligt ist und an der Overwatch League in die Geld reingebaut, gehört irgendwas.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das über kurz oder lang dann der ganzen Sache auch zum Verhängnis werden könnte.
Weil das dann viele sagen, okay ey, warum stecke ich hier überhaupt Geld rein, wenn ich im Endeffekt nichts da von mir ist.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das aber hinten losgeht. Hinten losgehen kann.
Hinten losgeht. Hinten losgehen kann.
Ja, ich hatte ja vorhin schon erzählt, ich will nicht wissen, wie sehr mittlerweile, gibt es eigentlich andere Streamer,
ich habe es ja am Anfang gesagt, ich bin da gar nicht so 100% auf Laufen, gibt es irgendwelche andere Streamer auf Twitch,
die auch nur annähernd an diese Menge Zuschauer kommen.
Ich weiß, Faker von LOL hatte mal 120k oder so beim ersten Stream auf Twitch.
Aber gibt es andere Streamer? Klar, es gibt noch viele andere große Streamer,
wie Dr. Disrespect oder so, der macht auch irgendwie seine 15k.
Du hast dann irgendwie xQc, der macht seine 10k. Du hast Lyric und Seagull hast du noch.
Und du hast welche, die machen auch irgendwie 15k, sonst war es k. Aber 150k?
Gibt es, gibt es, ja, ok, ok, ok, dass das ab und zu mal für einzelne Channels gibt, die das haben, ist klar.
Aber gibt es, gibt es noch mehr Leute auf Twitch, die regelmäßig, das ist ja nicht so, dass er das nur einmal hatte,
die regelmäßig 100k plus Zuschauer haben? Ja, ich meine ja, Ninja.
Gibt es noch andere, wen kennt ihr noch, der regelmäßig 100k plus Zuschauer auf Twitch hat?
Das ist so krass viel, ey.
Ich meine, in Deutschland bist du ja mit, keine Ahnung, 150, 200, 250 Zuschauer hast du, das ist schon viel.
Aber gut, Deutschland, ja, null.
Da habe ich, da habe ich ihr die Hoffnung aufgegeben, dass da mal Leute sich gescheiten Konzert angucken.
Deutschland ist so das typische, das typische casual let's play Land.
Mir fällt, mir fällt nichts anderes ein in dieser Richtung.
Deutschland guckt gerne Leuten zu, die möglichst schlecht in Spielen sind.
Fragt mich nicht warum, aber wir sind so, wir sind so das, dass Deutschland so das übertriebene casual let's play Land.
Klar, das gibt's, das gibt's in anderen Ländern auch, ja.
Es gibt die großen englischsprachigen let's play Channels und so.
Oder diese funny let's play Compilation, die gibt's auch in Massen.
Und natürlich gucken da auch mehr, weil das noch mehr Leute anspricht.
Aber so in der Menge, es gibt, es gibt verhältnismäßig Gaming-Channels, gibt's in Deutschland so viele, so einfach.
Leute, die nicht spielen, können aber halt unterhaltsame let's plays machen.
Also ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht negativ oder so.
Es ist halt nicht gefragt in Deutschland, wenn du ein Spiel, also nicht, sondern nicht gefragt in Deutschland, wenn du ein Spiel gut kannst.
Es reicht, wenn du es, wenn du das nicht können unterhaltsam darstellst.
Da kannst du in Deutschland halt super erfolgreich im Gaming-Sektor mit sein.
Klar, und dieser Unterhaltungsfaktor ist mit Sicherheit auch eine Fähigkeit, die man haben kann.
Auch eine Fähigkeit, die man haben muss, ja, ohne Frage.
Aber kennt ihr den Pro-Gamer-Stream aus Deutschland, der viele Zuschauer hat? Mir fällt keiner ein.
Der, der wohlgemerkt deutsche Zuschauer hat, ja.
Also wenn wir mal, sagen wir mal, es gäbe jetzt einen deutschen Pro, wenn es jetzt einen deutschen CSGO Pro gäbe,
dann würde es streamen und hätte 10.000 Zuschauer, dann wären das aber zum größten halt keine Deutschen.
Genau, cheesy Pros geht in Deutschland, geht es bei der Sache hauptsächlich rein um Unterhaltung.
Und Leute, die gut spielen, beziehungsweise gut spielen und unterhaltsam, sind gar nicht so gefragt.
Ja, Mundi ist kein Pro, oder?
Ich meine jetzt wirklich Leute, die verdammt gut sind. Also die auch, die auch in irgendwelchen Teams spielen und sonst was.
Guckt euch mal, wenn GetRide streamt, der hat auch irgendwie 4K-Zuschauer.
Oder guckt euch Seagull an, wenn der streamt, hat er 12K.
Das erinnert Leute, die sind nicht nur gut. Also bei Punkt 2 Seagull, muss ich sagen,
der Typ ist halt nicht nur saubmäßig gut, der ist auch, was das Game hergibt, unterhaltsam.
Piss dich Striker.
Seagull gucke ich quasi schon seit Anfang an.
Der ist nicht so, wisst ihr was, also an Seagulls Team finde ich einfach gut.
Der ist nicht dieses, es gibt für mich mehrere Arten von Unterhaltsam sein, auch auf YouTube und Twitch.
Es gibt so diese Mainstream-Let's-Play-Persönlichkeiten.
Leute, verpisst euch doch mal hier. Ich will doch eure Mops gar nicht killen, ich will jetzt einfach nur was sagen.
Hey Leute, hier ist wieder der Seagull.
Die Typen gibt es, die quasi 30 Sekunden Intro schon brauchen, jedes Mal, um irgendwie einen Spruch abzulassen.
Und dann gibt es halt, und das was ich halt als Seagulls Stream so gut finde ist,
der ist unterhaltsam halt mit dem Game, was er spielt.
Und nicht weil er irgendwie ultra-toxik wäre, und nicht weil er so gut ist.
Der ist unterhaltsam halt mit dem Game, was er spielt.
Und nicht weil er irgendwie ultra-toxik wäre, und nicht weil die Leute flamet, oder weil er jetzt so diese super Let's-Player-Persönlichkeit ist,
ist er halt, ist er ja gar nichts. Das hat überhaupt nichts mit diesen standardüberzogenen Let's-Player-Sachen zu tun,
sondern er spielt einfach gut und macht dabei auch unterhaltsame Kommentare.
Also, das kann man sich super angucken.
Hört sich wie der Friseur an. Ja, wenn wir sowas machen, hörst du?
Hört sich wie der Friseur an. Ja, wenn wir sowas machen, hört sich das oftmals ähnlich an, weil wir halt schon uns jahrelang die gleichen Scheiß erzählen.
Und halt auch die Leute immer gleich nachmachen, was das angeht.
Und auch ganz wichtig bei solchen Sachen ist natürlich, dass man immer erzählen muss, dass man,
dass die Zuschauer sind die Wichtigsten, ja? Also, man liebt seine Zuschauer, man ist seinen Zuschauern unendlich dankbar,
und alle Patreon-Leute unendlich dankbar und für den Support und T-Shirts verkaufen.
Ja, aber sowas wirklich pro Streams, das gibt es in Deutschland nicht. Das juckt keinen, das will keiner sehen.
In Deutschland kannst du bestimmt ganz gut, das geht aber in anderen Ländern auch, in Deutschland kannst du ganz gut mit
so, so, so, wie wir es nennen, educational content, kannst du auch schon gut was reißen, ja? Wenn du sowas machst wie
die zehn besten Fortnite Tipps, oder die zehn geheimen Fortnite Einsteigertricks, sowas in der Richtung, ja?
fortnite tipps oder die 10 geheimen fortnite einsteigertricks oder sowas in der richtung
ja das ist aber dann kein high-end content also kein content wo du sagst hey das richtet
sich an leute die richtig gut sind und noch so den letzten schliff rausholen wollen und sich
sachen abgucken wollen das ist nicht so gefragt in deutschland
sprichst jetzt von meinem channel klar demnächst gibt es fortnite tipps spiel zwar kein fortnite
aber ich nehme einfach das gameplay von erx und tue so als wüsste ich wovon ich rede
weiß dann 10 geheime fortnite tipps die nicht mal epic games kennt
war ich dann fünf unglaubliche fortnite hacks mit denen du deine gegner dominierst
wie viele tettversuche hattest du ich weiß ich könnte sein wenn ich dir das sage dass du dann
leicht getriggert bist wir hatten gestern zwei tettversuche easy wir haben ein tettversuch
gemacht dann ist es runtergegangen wieder auf du dann haben wir es dann haben wir es noch dann
haben wir es noch mal gefällt wieder auf pri dann haben wir es auf dann haben wir es wieder
auf auf duo gemacht und noch mal irgendwie dann haben wir es noch mal also irgendwie der zweite
zweite tettversucher so easy hat geklappt ich habe ein übertriebenes glück in dem game
mit wieviel failstacks ich bin mir nicht ich bin mir nicht mal sicher letztendlich haben wir
das ja zu zweit gemacht ich habe auch noch mehr oder weniger zugeguckt jemand der halt weiß was
er da macht weil ich habe halt vor dem game keinen schimmer ich glaube 72 oder sowas irgendwie so in
dem dreh 70 70 in dem dreh ich kann jetzt weder einschätzen ob das gut oder schlecht ist
patrick woher woher woher willst du das wissen hat der fabian was geschrieben oder
ja der frazier wer sonst so wieviel brauchen wir jetzt eigentlich noch letzte ne
ich habe einfach ein zu viel gekauft da ist letzter letzter letzter magas dauern wird ja auch mal zeit
morbid martin nutzt du noch unity media internet nein war ich nicht ab august ist das geschichte
ich habe das gekündigt kein unity media mehr sind sie aber selber daran schuld ich hätte
unity media auch weiter behalten hätten sie irgendwie konkurrenzfähigen bandbreite gehabt
was upload angeht wir sind ja auch ein bisschen irgendwie im letzten jahrtausend teilweise
hängen geblieben die meisten leute verstehe ich brauchen mehr download als upload aber in
der heutigen zeit braucht jeder der das internet halbwegs nutzt ordentlichen upload speed ja man
hat ganz viele sachen in der cloud liegen sonst irgendwie bei dropbox oder viele leute laden
urlaubsfotos videos was auch immer hoch also nen ordentlichen upload braucht eigentlich heutzutage
fast jeder es müssen keine 40 mit keine 100 mit oder sonst was sein aber es sollten nicht
fünf oder sechs oder zehn sein ein bisschen mehr darf da schon sein so und unity media hatte die
ganze zeit die möglichkeit dass man doppelt upload buchen kann also sprich man konnte sich
nen unity media tarif holen und dazu allein schon dass man dafür noch extra geld ausgeben muss
ist auch schon beknackt aber hier so ist es halt dann musste man sich hat man sich beispielsweise
doppelt upload geholt und konnte dann sagen okay man nimmt sich den tarif mit mit 400 down 10 ab
macht doppelt upload hat 20 also das heißt man 20 mit ab und 400 runter würde ich sagen das ist
ein ganz guter kompromiss es dürfte gerne noch ein bisschen mehr upload sein aber es ist okay so
und jetzt sind sie auf die idee gekommen ihre tarife umzustellen und die doppelt upload option
zu entfernen das heißt du bekommst garantiert nur noch 10 mit upload und das ist einfach zu
wenig also das ist was heißt es ist nicht gerechtfertigt noch mal dass ich einen neuen
tarif abschließe und wechsel und mehr geld bezahle für mehr ab für mehr download den ich
eigentlich brauche ich bräuchte eigentlich mehr upload also es hätte sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt
für mich zu upgraden und die telekom hat halt die möglichkeit 100 mit down und 40 ab
da denke ich okay es dürfte mir jetzt gerne ein bisschen mehr download sein 100 down ist
jetzt nicht die welt aber es reicht dicke und es sind 40 mit ab 40 ab ist halt wenn man videos
hochladen will die dann irgendwie 34 gigabyte sind wichtig das ist essentiell sonst sitzt du
ewig rum also jetzt wirklich ewig als ich angefangen habe videos hochzuladen auf youtube
hatte ich 384k wisst ihr wie lange das wie wie ewig das gedauert hat da was hochzuladen und es
waren damals call of duty videos 720p mit mit 5 m bit die videos waren im prinzip hatten die
400 mb oder sowas hier nach 300 oder noch weniger das war nichts und es hat mit 384k das hat ewig
gedauert die ip die ipv6 die ipv4 problematik bestand bei dir weiterhin nee die habe ich
weggekriegt nachdem ich so lange noch öffentlich auf twitter geflammt habe
es ist eh der wahnsinn wie viel öffentlich flamen auf twitter bewirkt wenn man ein paar
follower hat dass mein klo anfangen kann zu brennen hatte ich euch ja mal erzählt
und ich habe mich aber den gemeldet schon vor monaten bei geberit dem hersteller nachdem
es bekannt wurde ja es ist gerade keiner da war die sekretärin dran und so ja es hat keiner
da der techniker meldet sich hat keiner gemeldet habe ich noch mal angerufen und techniker
meldet sich war es wieder keiner gemeldet hat sich monatelang nichts getan ja und die aussage
von geberit war ja ich soll mein klo einfach ausschalten also quasi ich soll das ausschalten
wofür ich es gekauft habe ja ich kauf mir noch kein kein klo mit schnick schnack quasi den ich
dann ausschalte monatelang so bescheuert warum soll ich das dann kaufen so und irgendwann nach
vier monaten oder so habe ich mir ja okay tut sich nichts öffentlich auf twitter geflamed
etgeberit natürlich auch wieder leute auf twitter muss ich ja mal sagen es habt ihr das habt ihr
sehr gut gemacht ja auch die leute auf twitter natürlich auch alles schön drüber lustig gemacht
und ich glaube noch noch um 21 45 oder so hat sich ins des social media team gemeldet
und wollte wollte kontakte haben muss man sich mal muss man sich mal geben ja ignored bis zum
geht nicht mehr einfach mal öffentlich geflamed haben sie wahrscheinlich auf meinen account
geguckt festgestellt auf scheiße das können jetzt ja 25.000 leute lesen und dann müssen wir
dem antworten vorher müssen wir dem nicht antworten jetzt müssen wir dem antworten ich
muss mal ein bisschen was was wegschweißen ja aber das ganze ist dann natürlich gut ausgegangen ich
muss sagen der techniker da lang komm ist er war sehr kompetent er wusste bescheid was er macht
und er hat sogar noch kostenlos die spülung repariert also da kann ich nichts sagen letztendlich
haben sie das super gemacht daumen hoch ja wenn es echt so auch gleich wenn du probleme hast wie
du schreibst mit dpd mit hermes mit egal wem öffentlich auf twitter flame ist das beste
weil die haben mittlerweile extra social media typen die da sitzen wahrscheinlich auch auf
facebook bei denen und halt drauf gucken dass die das dass die jeweilige und das jeweilige
unternehmen gut da steht und dass das geht so schnell wenn man über social media flamet
also dafür ist es echt gut dass es sowas gibt ich muss mein klo ausschalten ja es ist halt so
moment wo rennt wo rennt ich eigentlich es ist halt so ich muss halt mein klo aus wusste
mein klo ausschalten weil sonst konnte mein klo anfangen zu brennen natürlich hatte ich
zwischendrin immer immer an ja ausgeschaltet ich habe das reinigungsmittel raus sind die mobs
sind ausgemacht mobs kommen wir brauchen noch 170 nahgas 180 das müssen wir noch
jetzt hinkriegen 180 nahgas und dann können wir weg dann sind wir fertig hier
genau patrick drei monate gekackt ja das habe ich an so verschwörungen habe ich noch gar nicht
gedacht er hat geschrieben deswegen wird das internet in deutschland nicht ausgebaut weil
dann könnten mehr leute öffentlich flamen auf twitter das ist es endlich endlich haben
wir die wahrheit rausgefunden man ich brauche mobs ich brauche mobs please give mobs
ich brauche dann immer viele 570 stück ne fuck 170
alles weg
nach respawn langsamer respawn da ist hamas da ist hamas
in wieder fast
ja jetzt haben wir das vorhin gang aus den augen verloren kennt ihr den noch kennt ihr
noch irgendwelche streamer die regelmäßig 100k plus haben da war nämlich noch gar nicht fertig
vor allem bei mir fallen da keiner ein also regelmäßig nicht ab und zu mal hat einmal
gehabt weil er irgendwie was gemacht hat ich finde ich finde der sprung ist einfach übertrieben
krass oft wird gewesen für mich waren im kopf und es ist ja im prinzip immer noch so leute
über 10k waren einfach verdammt groß auf twitch und es ist ja so das ist ja immer noch so
10k plus also so 25k haben die wenigsten erreicht das waren ab und zu mal die ganz großen die
haben das geknackt so ab 10k gehörst du zu zu zu zu eine handvoll oder näher zu sagen wir
zu den top top 15 oder so ja channels auf twitch und dass es jetzt einfach mal jemand gibt der
der die zwischenschritte komplett überspringt und und nicht und einfach mal nur hinten dran
hängt ist der wahnsinn was hat er eigentlich vorher gemacht hat er erst mit dem spiel angefangen
oder hatte vorher keiner geguckt und jetzt gucken in viele mit fortnight
hallo pro es gibt noch hallo pros ach so hallo ja gut das hat wahrscheinlich keiner geguckt oder
hallo ist jetzt ja nicht mal so das gefragte gelb ist eigentlich schade dass er das nicht gepusht
haben oder es nicht geschafft haben richtig zu pushen weil ich finde hallo war das einzige
konsolen esport game wo man sagen konnte das ist das ist was also mir gefällt das viel besser wenn
ich mir da irgendwie den hallo turnier angucke als den call of duty turnier ich finde hallo war
das einzige game wo man sagen könnte das wäre ein super aushänge schild für konsolen esport
gewesen aber hallo ist ja nicht mal so nicht mal so gefragt jetzt der master chief
doch so richtig jetzt noch raus genau h1 z1 dass das noch gibt es war dieses zombie ding von
sony was dann später nicht mehr sony war und danach irgendwie bettel royal war und dann
keiner mehr gespielt gar nicht weil ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher ob das wird keiner mehr
spielen da ist ein zelt oder ist es ein grafikklitsch das grafikklitsch
video was soll es sonst sein ja super jetzt ist nacht jetzt kriege ich mehr xp und jetzt
bin ich fertig jetzt gehen wir zu desert fogans fogans alter fogans aber auf dem weg zu fogans
wo sie was zu essen holen ja meinst du hainz z1 oder meinst du warts meinst du meinst du warts
weil war zwar ja das gam game oder oder wie es neuerdings heißt infestation survival
zu survival stories oder so haben sie umbenannt warum haben sie das game wohl umbenannt vielleicht
weil das game die leute gescampt hat wie sau kann aber nicht sein das war die zeit wo zombie
games gehyped waren als dann sony irgendwann mit h1 z1 angekommen ist war war zombie games
eigentlich schon wieder out ich habe ein cheater cheater dragon height kaufen hier braucht doch
keiner verkaufe ich auch das richtige ich gucke mal das richtige dass ich hab hier
das falsche verkaufen wenn so unaufgeräumt ist okay dann reppen wir noch mal kurz wenn
man nämlich zu fogans gehen das dauert jetzt eine weile sind wir sind wir fünf minuten
unterwegs und können nicht zurück gucken dass man info ein bisschen mehr krieg da ich
so viel nehmen kann wie irgendwie geht so ich glaube am meisten am meisten wiegen die
tränke tränke ja 2,5 das wiegt ordentlich der rest der rest wiegt gar nicht viel die
tränke sind das das das schwere egal gehen wir los ich könnte ich nehme einfach mein
kameel mit wo ist mein kameel was machst du eigentlich ich mache gürtelquest aber wobei
ich kann ich könnte jetzt schon mal upgraden den gürtel habe ich schon mal besseren gürtel
für folgen spaschen wo ist wo ist der upgrade stellen wupps wie ging das wie upgraden wir
den scheiß jetzt einfach mal normalerweise kann man den kamer noch die crafting materiale
anklicken hier ne okay das muss man wahrscheinlich über play spirit machen das ding kann doch
überhaupt nicht fehlen was erzählen der play spirit da für ein scheiß guck mal 100 prozent
ja anscheinend ist low and high chance of failure versteht man nicht so genau hoho es
ist nicht fehlgeschlagen wer hat das gedacht
so jetzt jetzt hat nämlich der gürtel schon viel mehr ap gegen monster als mein anderer
krabbelt ja und für die für den gürtel mache ich die quest wo ist wo ist achmed mit cover
und bei billig kameel hat es hat weder einen sattel noch sonst was mich wundert dass jetzt
keine irgendwie annele oder so was noch gesperrt hat ok moment ich muss mal kurz in mich gehen
wie kam es noch mal zu fogans ja hier das passt schon fogans alter fogans da unten so
komm ich genau bei fogans raus wenn ich hier reite und und und nein max stop abspringen
genau ich muss den gürtel anziehen und ich muss vor allem noch mal vorher die steine
von alten quest abgeben und neue steine holen weil ich habe mir gar keine neuen steine geholt
nicht stumm ich hängen geblieben
und
wir hätten es gar nicht machen müssen wir hätten es gar nicht machen müssen ich habe
gerade vier ich habe gerade vier vier nager stones voll gemacht dabei hätte ich einfach
nur ein nager stone voll machen müssen easy clap dafür mehr exp gemacht man macht ja
nichts umsonst sondern desert fogans muss ich auch nur so einen kacke stone voll machen
was max heute 20 uhr note war was ich soll note war spielen ja ich kann ja eh spam
ich check es gerade ich habe doch die ich habe doch die nager geschichte schon abgegeben
oh nee ich weiß was ist ich habe die quest nicht angenommen vorher was ab leute ich habe
die quest ich habe ich muss den scheiß jetzt noch mal machen das mache ich nicht das mache
ich heute nicht noch mal können vergessen können vergessen das war ich heute noch mal
ich habe die quest angenommen und ich habe die stones abgegeben da oh nee noch ich mache
jetzt ich mache jetzt nicht noch mal vier mal nagers vier mal nager leck mich am arsch
das war ich nett ich gehe jetzt ich gehe jetzt desert fogans ich mache jetzt fogans
alter fogans ja fabian kann man machen ich kann nachher eh spam ich gehe jetzt fogans
10k mobs für nix nee nicht 2k 2k mobs war es aber den gürtel können wir schon mal anlegen
so glaube mal der ist besser der ist schon mal auf jeden fall besser als dieses komische
ding da bringt ja gar nichts doch auf geht's desert fogans ach du hast auch 10k für nix
gemacht quest oh man ja fabian du musst dann aber noch mal vor ins ts kommen wir mal kurz
erklären was da wie das genau abläuft weil ich hab doch keine ahnung von da ich so ungefähr
weiß was ich klicken muss und was dann passiert und so dass das lustig ist mir hat das dass
das sinnlose rumkraten hat mir jetzt auch wenn ich die ganze zeit rüber rumgeweckert
hat hat mir insofern in soweit spaß gemacht dass es mich gar nicht großartig nervt dass
ich das jetzt nochmal machen muss wir sehen schöne wüsten grafikfehler das nervt mich
gar nicht also ich mach das jetzt nochmal aber jetzt machen wir erstmal fogans ich hoffe
dass die richtung stimmt aber müsste eigentlich stimmen wir sind hier so schräg runter ja
das müsste passen man kann hier übelst cheaten was wüstennavigation angeht indem man einfach
hier am rand guckt in welche richtung man dann da lang läuft das ist eigentlich überhaupt
nicht will dass man in der wüste nicht navigieren kann würde sinn machen wenn man quest platz
man kann doch massig quests annehmen kann doch hier massig massig quests was kann ob
es überhaupt ein limit für quests gibt es überhaupt ein limit für quests guck mal ich
hab massig quests
fogans ich hoffe wir müssen ein bisschen höher reiten 25 ok was joggst du momentan so ich
zocke haus automatisierung einrichten und ein bisschen video 30 cap ok ich hab mich
noch nie gepackt hab ich jetzt wenigstens vor habe ich jetzt überhaupt fogans da uns
mitgenommen nein oh man meine güte jetzt ich habe keine fogans da uns dabei so voll
brain auf ich habe jetzt falsch gedacht habe der quest ist die quest ist anders habe ich
jetzt ein fogans da und geholt habe ich nix mehr easy clap ja komm reiten wir nochmal zurück
muss nicht in der city echt wo fabian wo kann ich wo kann ich sonst noch fogans da uns
holen gibt's gibt's gibt's bei gibt's bei fogans fogans da uns reitsch jetzt weiter
beim acht beim not manager das ist nice du meinst hier bei dem bei dem data hier da
hier irgendwo oder da hier der der typ da den stopp der ist das der da auf dem felsen
rum steht ok gut da ist halb so wird zum glück kann man das kann man das vom not manager
holen so wiegt das täusche irgendwas nein das lass achmed in ruhe wir sind schon mal
auf jeden fall richtig wenn wir hier unten sind wir nämlich jetzt gerade hier irgendwo
da sind wir da sind wir sind wir richtig wie die o weiß wie schatten aussehen tete
ande pochamp ja so sieht's aus hätte ande mit zwei tries oder fabian zwei stück zwei
versuche warum kann man in der wüste nicht navigieren weil sich weil sich perl bis gedacht
hat wüste ist das ultra gefährliche highlevel gebiet was ist ja letztendlich weiß nicht
so wirklich ist oder die schatten sehen nach einem exklusiven tausend acht sti feature
aus eindeutig oder mal was fogans hier rein ist immer gleich im zweifel falls immer auf
den best drauf doch dass die fogans willa geht sie ohne rein die willa ist der fabian
entscheidet mir das zeug doch ich hab doch keine ahnung von den gemm
ich an als ist die musik hängen geblieben
ich mach jetzt meinen anderen foganstein kaputt und fängt er an sich aufzuladen und ich muss
noch mehr fogans können moin klapper du klapper klapper klaus ja der ex reagiert sehr allergisch
was grafikfehler und ruckler angeht vor allem was ruckler angeht der hat also der hat den
ruckel sensor irgendwie damit er merkt ruckler an stellen wo keiner ruckler merkt
so wo war jetzt jeder spot fürs kamel ich glaube hier irgendwo kann man kann man bestimmt
hier einfach in die ecke stellen ist kamel
so dann gehts schnell zu uns mal zum not manager aber ist ganz schön dunkel
ja das stimmt aber ohne scheißleute wenn ihr wenn ihr mal wissen wollt wieviel frames ihr
im game habt ohne den benchmark anzuwerfen dann fragt ihr mal fragt den exer sagt euch
dass der guckt sich das game an spiel zwei spiel spiel zwei stunden rank ich weiß nicht
wo ich bin spiel zwei stunden rank und sagt euch durchschnitts fps und vor allem aufs
frame drop skippt ach doch das weiß ich wieder wo wir sind da rennt er der wizard so jetzt
muss ich auch den not manager finden da war irgendwo unten links
und wir sind gar nicht da wo ich gedacht habe wo wir sind da muss ich da muss ich mich jetzt
erstmal orientieren wo wir sind wir sind hier rausgekommen wir sind schon unten wir sind
gar nicht oben wir sind unten da ist er doch
so und wo gibt es jetzt beim not manager ach hier da ist er ach das ist auch der gleiche
typ ich bin gespannt wie sie uns erklären wollen dass der auf der ganzen welt mehrfach
vorhanden ist jetzt muss ich jetzt muss ich vor ganz beschen dass ich bin jetzt da und
kaufen kann das schlimm oder schlimm schrecklich schrecklich ich habe kein geld kann man hier
auch was verkaufen kann man nicht was verkaufen oder acht ist das wäre ich doch in die stadt
zurückgegangen und dann was mache ich jetzt am besten so meine frage an die pros wie kriege
ich das hier am besten hin ohne dass ich wieder zurück rennen muss wie macht man das jetzt
am besten das ist richtig so ich kann da nichts ja du ja doch du weißt das du wirst das natürlich
wirst es natürlich voraus an ohne geld rumlaufen licht man wenn ich hab den nix wie viel geld
kriegt man für ein folgen besch ich meine fänge ich würde ein bisschen luft ok da gibt
es keine großartige möglichkeit was zu kaufen und verkaufen dann fresse ich jetzt eine pizza
dann wird jetzt nicht damit es nicht weiter weiter gequestet da wird als pizza gefressen
weil zellen kam aber dem ja nix ja leute dann gehe ich jetzt pizza futtert fabian bist du
jetzt bist du jetzt daheim schon ja ok dann werde ich jetzt extrem ausmachen und pizza
fuddern und wenn du schon daheim ist kannst du mir mal erklären kurz im discord was dann
da später eigentlich genau ist und vor allem was wie das so funktioniert da ich so ein
bisschen ahnung wenigstens hab das wäre dann schlecht das wäre sehr sehr nice ja leute
dann würde ich sagen sehen wir uns vielleicht morgen da mache ich die restliche quest fertig
mal gucken wie schlimm die die pen quest wird für das ding für den für den gürtel
und wir sehen uns morgen bis denn macht's gut tschüss